Hey, Matthew.
We're just waiting for Morgan.
He should be here in about three minutes.
So we're going to see what happens this time.
And don't be surprised if only a very few listeners, including yourself, show up.
This is a topic that most people don't want to really engage with.
Hey, Morgan, I just sent you the co-host invite.
Co-host invite.
Hopefully you'll get that.
I know we had a little trouble last time.
X is trying to stop you.
I think the solution last time.
I think the solution last time was that you had to shut down the app and then start it up again.
I'm not sure.
So if we have the same problem today, that's probably the first thing we should try.
Oh, that was great.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, can you hear me?
All right.
Yeah, I can hear you well.
Yeah, I'm using my earbuds this time.
I had issues with them last time I tried.
But yeah, as long as I'm coming pretty clear, that's good.
Yeah, I mean, maybe a little muffled, but I don't think it's a problem.
Don't be surprised if not as many people show up for this one, because this is a topic a lot of people like to avoid.
And particularly, we have a lot of UFOX people, and one of the suggested reasons that I think everyone forgets, because we're so far from the Cold War, but one of the reasons that it was always suggested that the UFO phenomenon could also function as a form of propaganda was that it would allow people or allow foreign governments or our own government,
or whomever, to manipulate people's opinions about the use of nuclear weapons.
And one way that happened was, of course, almost every UFO objectee during the Cold War and following the Cold War was told about the dangers of nuclear weapons, and you have to go back and stop them from using the nuclear weapons.
And the other one was people were led to believe that saucers were shutting down ICBMs, which maybe they were.
I don't know.
But the inference was that they would shut down all ICBMs, and therefore, we wouldn't be allowed to have a nuclear war.
So those are two sort of quasi-religious ideas that people have.
Also, there's a lot of religious-type prophecy around nuclear war that comes out of the UFO community or did back in the day.
So, you know, some of the people who usually listen to us likely dismiss the idea that we could have a world war.
A lot of the alternative community is sort of like that.
For instance, like the Tesla thing.
Tesla was a real guy.
He had, like, very real technology.
And we use that very real technology today.
And we know that the government, our government, and other governments have access to some of that technology that we don't have access to, obviously, right?
However, people led to believe that that technology invalidates the use of nuclear weapons or weapons of mass destruction.
And that's clearly not the case.
So that's one thing that the alternative community has always been used for, is to dissuade people from thinking seriously about the topic of nuclear war or World War III in general.
All right.
Hello, everyone.
B, Matthew, Miss.
Hopefully, some more people are coming.
But don't be surprised if not many people show up for this one.
I'm JT.
I'm an astrologer.
I'm not a remote viewer.
This is Morgan.
Morgan is the Professor X of our age and a very skilled remote viewer and runs Intuitive Underground, which is a remote viewing group.
And they have a website, intuitiveunderground.com.
Morgan, is your Learn RV your – or is it – what's the exact – what's your website?
We keep forgetting at the end, so I want to get it out at the beginning.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh, yeah.
It's the training site.
Yeah, it's the remote viewing training.
I was just kidding around about the Professor X thing, although you can be the Professor X if you want to be.
I don't have a website currently.
I'm available for consultation if anyone who listens to this later has any interest in that on a donation basis.
But otherwise, at this point, I don't promote myself.
I might get one.
I don't know.
Anyway, so obviously with the Iran situation, the war has been on people's minds recently.
But the thing about the topic of nuclear war is, number one, it's – well, World War III.
I'd say that.
Hey, Alpha.
Okay.
I don't know why we're requesting to speak at the beginning, but sure.
So, the topic of World War III – back to listener.
Okay.
Okay, this is acting crazy for me, spaces.
So the topic of World War III is highly manipulated, right?
It's manipulated by both – we can assume our own government, and we can assume that's likely for our own benefit, or at least on a level of national security, right?
For our benefit, and it's manipulated by foreign governments who want to control the American populace's thoughts about world wars and weapons of mass destruction as a way of using the electoral system and popular opinion to shape our response as a nation.
So a lot of people don't have much information about world wars or the possibility of world war.
And when you get into predictive communities, for instance, the community of astrologers, a lot of people – normalcy bias takes over, and a lot of people want to ignore what they see.
So if they see evidence of something like a progression towards a world war, then they'll maybe mention it and then not mention it again.
Or they'll mention it with, like, laughter or eye rolls or a body language that is intended to get people to dismiss the possibility because that makes them more comfortable.
And then, you know, normally bias kicks in, people want to make a living, like, if someone is a content creator, if they're an influencer, they're hoping to make their full-time living as an influencer.
So they have to worry about what their subscribers think, right?
And they also have to worry about, like, what the general public thinks.
And they also know that if they convince people that, you know, world war is imminent and people need to prepare, that's likely to lead to their financial well-being being compromised.
So everyone sort of has an investment to not be honest about, about nuclear war, world war.
I give Morgan some links and the links to Post in the Nest, the links that I'm throwing, hopefully going to have him put up there,
are links to the two major subscriber services in the remote viewing community and material they've put out about the possibility of the war escalating.
Hey, JC, do you want me to put those up there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, throw them right up there, man.
Okay, I'll do that.
Cool.
And the reason that I'm asking him to put them up there, well, one, it's because I'm tech incompetent and don't know how to put things in the nest.
Two, they, we don't necessarily support them.
They don't, definitely don't support us, right?
They're not, Farsight Prime and Future Forecasting Group are not friends of this space.
We may have personal relations.
I don't have any personal relationships.
People here who frequent this space may have personal relationships with them.
There's not, this isn't a space about criticizing them in any way.
I'm just saying that we don't have a relationship.
I don't have a relationship with them.
All right.
So I'm not having the information posted, supporting them or trying to send people their way to subscribe to their service.
I'm having it put up so that we can show you that they, they see this information in general.
Remote viewers who look into the concept of the war escalating see that it does.
They see it often, they see it often and in my experience, it seemed as if it started showing up in remote viewing data three or four years ago.
I had some, I had some, I had some, I don't know, I had some differences of opinion with both astrologers and remote viewers over the last few years who weren't talking about the war escalating.
Because I know that they were clearly getting data on that subject and very compelling data.
So we're throwing those links up there so people can see, yep, they're, they're seeing the war escalating and they all know that it's going to happen.
And I'll tell you any competent astrologer knows that more than likely, more likely than not, uh, the war is going to escalate.
And anyone who tells you that they don't see that in the astrology, I would, I'm not one to like try to sabotage other people's gig, but I wouldn't really trust someone who says that they're an astrologer and they, they, they're unfamiliar with any, um, with any astrological indications.
The war is going to broaden, uh, because that clearly is something that's in the astrology, um, normalcy bias, right?
I think that we've, we've talked about this in other spaces, but this is what, this is what's happening.
Um, you know, everyone just wants to sort of not think about the hard future.
Everyone wants to sort of think about their own wellbeing.
And that's why you'll see this information come up.
You'll see them run these RV sessions.
You might see an astrologer make a video about it, although unlikely because astrology, astrology influences, if anything, are less honest than remote viewing influences.
Um, and more, uh, in my experience, um, I guess self-centered would be the, I was going to try to find a diplomatic way of saying that.
Um, but then you'll see them go back the next week and talk about something else, something mundane.
Um, and the problem with that is that their, their non-reaction to the information, they're seeing it, acknowledging it.
Um, and then the next week going back to their pet projects, uh, talking about Bitcoin, talking about crypto, um, talking about these probably imaginary futures, uh, that they would like to see.
Um, and from, from an astrological perspective, talking about people's relationships, because that's what draws people in, right?
That's where your money is, um, that leads the people who see the videos to a false sense of security, right?
So they, they see these videos, they see information about world war is, is possible.
Um, but then the person who's telling them that information doesn't seem to pay much attention to it.
And next week they're telling them about how everyone's going to get rich selling crypto, right?
It just leads them to not take the information seriously.
And, um, it leads them to like unconsciously discount the possibility.
I think anyone who's honest with themselves will know that we are clearly moving in the direction of, um, of a broad global military conflict.
And we have been for a long time.
The, the information about how this would unfold has been around since the 1980s or earlier, the 1960s.
So we know how this would unfold because there was, um, there was a genre of literature from the 1960s to 1980s, 90s, uh, referred to as defector literature.
And defector literature was, um, were books put out by Russian defectors, um, maybe a Chinese defector or two, but generally Russian defectors, uh, during the cold war who would come to the country.
They wouldn't have any other way to really support themselves.
So they would put out books detailing Russian war plans in the, in the case that the U S and Russia escalated towards a war.
There's actually, I mean, from that time period, there was pretty detailed information about how it would happen.
And it may not be any coincidence that we've, um, that we're 20, 30 years, you know, 40 years past, um, past those releases of those books.
Um, um, so that people would sort of forget, uh, that information because time doesn't really change the way a conflict like this would work.
Right.
It's the way the conflict will play out.
If it does are based on the physical limitations that the world imposes on the two parties.
So even if they fought in a hundred years, you would still be looking, um, they would still be looking to use the same strategies, the same tactics.
Now I'm looking at my, uh, my jot list there.
So, um, starting with the astrology, uh, we have unprecedented astrological events.
And then now every year people say that, and particularly astrologers, because they need to make money.
So they need to keep people's attention.
So they say, oh, well, in our lifetimes, we've never seen this astrological alignment in the sky.
And, um, of course that's true.
There are probably astrological alignments fairly routinely that no one has, uh, has lived through before.
However, um, what we're approaching, what we're, we're involved in right now, um, is, is, is, is a legitimately like big deal astrologically.
Um, we have a, a once in approximately that as far as, as we're aware, um, once in 6,400 year astrological alignment coming up.
And, um, um, okay, so it's hard to articulate this stuff in a way that's engaging.
I'm sorry that if I'm, I'm being halting.
So, um, the planet Earth or the simulation, however you want to look at it, it has an astrological chart and that's the mundane Zodiac.
It's the one that you look at, um, the wheel that you look at that everyone else's chart is superimposed on.
Uh, it's not just a random wheel.
It is, in fact, the astrological chart for planet Earth or the simulation.
The ascendant on that chart, the point of materialization, the, the, the most important degree in the chart and thus the most important degree in astrology is zero degrees Aries.
Zero degrees Aries, the ascendant for the world, the ascendant for the simulation, uh, whatever transit occurs at that point defines history from that point until the next major transit occurs on that point.
So the last one was a, um, a Uranus conjunct Jupiter, um, aspect, uh, I think it was in the nineties, but I didn't write it down.
Anyways, that's sort of defined or has defined, um, history from that time.
Um, and if you are aware of like, um, awakening electronics, technology, uh, electricity and Jupiter expansion, um, you're talking about like the expansion of the, um, of the information age.
You're talking about the expansion of technology.
Um, you're talking about, uh, an expansion of globalism, et cetera.
Um, that all could be indicated from that, um, that aspect.
However, right now, what we're dealing with, um, we're dealing with two major astrological situations.
The first one is, um, the conjunction of, of Saturn and Neptune at zero degrees Aries.
And that conjunction is exact, uh, on February 20th, 2026.
That's, um, again, 6,400 years.
The last time was, uh, 4360 BC.
We don't precisely know what was happening at that time because civilization was pretty young.
There was, um, a volcano.
Some people believe that the great flood events may have happened at that time as well.
However, the, the natural disaster people, the people who talk about pole shifts and solar flares and solar micro novas, commentary impacts, et cetera.
They put a 6,400 year, um, uh, cycle on those events.
So every 6,400 years, there'll be a, a minor catastrophe.
I mean, major from our perspective.
Um, and every 12,800 years, uh, there would be a, a major, major, major catastrophe.
Um, they're predicting the pole shift people, of course, that we're close to the 12,800 year, major, major catastrophe.
But from our perspective, what's important is this conjunction of Saturn and Neptune at the, uh, the world point, zero degrees Aries seems to coincide with those predictions.
Um, what it means though, from a astrological perspective, when you, when you take like pole shift stuff out of there, uh, Saturn and Neptune, when they conjunct in Aries, well, Saturn and Neptune conjunctions in general would tend to indicate like war, plague, uh, collapse of, of, uh, communities, um, natural disasters.
Uh, when you're talking about that happening in Aries, uh, when you're talking about that happening in Aries, which it does from time to time, uh, then Saturn and Neptune in Aries indicates, um, the fall of, uh, the, the fall of the nations, um, or dynasties, empires.
Particularly when it's in Aries, it also recently in history has included Russia, but not, um, in the, not from the sense of Russia collapsing, but Russia, uh, as being part of the collapse of other dynasties, nations, empires.
It hasn't happened in Aries, but it hasn't happened in zero degrees Aries though.
So because zero degrees Aries is the world point, you might assume, um, like our, our, our best interpretation would be that this event would indicate the same type of, um, possibility of plague, possibility of war, possibility of natural event.
A natural crisis leading to the collapse global order.
I know that sounds like, um, a rather big, um, you know, a sort of a rather grand thing to say based on one conjunction, but it's because of where it is.
So if you had read that a hundred years ago and you were familiar with the astrology, you could have said, okay, so around 2026, you know, civilization is facing a major, major crisis.
Um, right now, today, uh, Saturn and Neptune are coming into a very close, um, a very close or, um, they're not exactly conjunct.
But on the 4th of July, they'll be about as close as they will be until that point in time.
And it's about, I think half a degree, it could be, uh, a third of a degree.
And so what we're seeing in the world around us right now, um, is a reflection of, or foreshadowing of what should be the major theme over the next few years.
As, um, as we move past the, the 4th, uh, first Neptune goes retrograde and then Saturn goes retrograde.
So at that point, you're going to see the beginning of an escalatory crisis of some kinds.
Because what happens with these long-term astrological transits is at first, the planets will move to that degree, past that degree, and you'll see the problem.
When they retrograde, you'll, you'll enter the crisis.
And eventually, when they move past that degree again, uh, you'll see the resolution of the crisis.
Uh, so we would hope, um, that the crisis would resolve in some way, uh, in 2026.
Now, people always say, um, well, the astrology of 2027 and 2026 is, is so good that we're looking at some sort of utopian moment in human history.
And I've always said to them, well, that's not actually what it says.
What it means is things are going to improve markedly over where they are today.
But in that period of time between now and then, like things could get pretty bad, right?
So if humanity hits bottom in, in 2026, then 2027 could be a thousand times better than that.
And still really not something you want to experience.
That's really how you have to look at it with this, with this particular astrology.
We're entering Barbolt's basket.
André Barbolt was a famous French astrologer who, they always come up with their own systems.
He had his own graphing system.
And he was, uh, he said that, uh, the best astrological weather of the, of the century would be 2026, 2027, 2028, um, because of this basket configuration.
So what's happening is while Saturn and Neptune are forming a conjunction at zero degrees Aries, um,
Pluto is at the beginning of Aquarius and Uranus is at the beginning of Gemini.
Uh, also Jupiter will be, um, at the, uh, in the early stages of, of Leo, uh, next year.
And this form sort of, if you look at it on the astrological chart, it forms a basket configuration.
Like it looks physically like a basket.
So people have been looking forward to that.
Um, but actually it's, they're not really understanding what's going on.
So the, um, the relationship between Uranus and this Saturn, uh, uh, Neptune conjunction and Pluto in the Saturn-Neptune conjunction is going to, um, it, like, it takes the negative energy or it's not really negative, but it takes the crisis, catastrophe, catastrophic energy.
And it flows together harmoniously.
That's what it, uh, trine means.
So it also, it's also going to flow together and work together in a very harmonious way.
And since we're looking at a major catastrophe, then we're looking at a catastrophe that like really sort of, um, really just sort of spirals, uh, very quickly.
It would be another way of, of looking at it.
We have, um, an astrologer who's a very well-known astrologer and he's, he's good.
Uh, not a friend of the space.
Um, his name is Dan Waits.
I had Morgan put a video up there.
Um, he, who runs world astrology report.
I recommend it for the astrology.
Um, yeah, so that, that's all I'm going to say.
I recommend the world astrology report on YouTube for the astrology because Dan does it.
He's a pretty good, um, astrologer and he's a decent historian.
He puts those together and he creates some good content and he's the better content creator than I will ever be.
Uh, so they, um, he hired an astrologer.
It was actually, this is one of the reasons it's a little bit of attention.
Morgan and I, um, have an Astro RV project that we've been working on that Morgan has been spearheading for a couple of years now.
Um, Dan was aware of that project or should be aware of that project.
And he, um, he got together with a remote viewer and he did his own Astro RV project, which was fine, which is great.
Didn't necessarily do it the way that we would suggest.
Uh, however, uh, the video is up there and, uh, Dan is a, is a great mundane astrologer and he specifically looked at the August 9th date, which I probably should have done.
But I always think in big terms, uh, on August 9th, this, these planetary alignments are going to be, quote, activated by an opposition from Mars to Saturn and Neptune in conjunction.
And that means that August 9th and, and forward is the period where we should really see these events, um, I don't know, manifest.
We should really see these events in the news.
The Saturn Mars opposition was something that happened during the, um, Cuban missile crisis.
So Dan is suggesting, and I think we could cause that, that might be a period where there is, um, a nuclear standoff of some kind.
But the remote viewer, and he's good, Josh Maitland, rockstar remote viewing, uh, the task was a little open-ended, but he saw all of the same things that everyone else sees.
And so, um, with the major streaming remote viewing services, Farsight Prime and future forecasting, um, with, uh, independent remote viewers and groups like Morgan, who haven't spent as much time looking into those particular targets.
Uh, with, uh, with proper, uh, certain, like, prophecies, right, both religious and non-religious prophecies, um, they tend to see the same basic outline for the conflict scenario.
And that is also what came up in, in Josh Maitland's, um, work with, uh, with Dan Waite.
So, um, we're going to talk today about what data Morgan may have.
We're, we're going to do a two-parter.
We were originally going to do this in one part, but we're going to do a two-parter, uh, because it's simply too much rambling to, to go through, like, all of the prophecies and predictions, you know, from all the cultures.
I spent two years working on, um, comparative eschatology back when I was a little smarter than I am now.
So, I, I could talk about, you know, I could just keep rattling through different cultures and what they said about how this conflict would happen, but we ought to break it up into, like, you know, bite, bite-sized pieces.
Um, and also, I'd just be working off of memory and probably should check all my sources first.
So, Morgan does have some information, um, possibly related to, uh, these subjects.
Um, the other Mopium groups do, and I just broke down the astrology for you.
So, with mundane astrology, you're looking at, you're looking at the broad outlines of the narrative of history, which you see in the movement of the outer planets.
And you're looking at the indication of crisis inflection points, which you see based on hard aspects between Mars and Saturn or eclipses.
That's, that's basically how, um, hard aspects from Mars, hard aspects from Saturn, hard aspects between Mars and Saturn and eclipses.
That is how you time these events as closely as possible.
Uh, the other way would be, uh, Uranus transits.
The reason that Uranus is important to this story, um,
when we look at the outer planets, all having moved signs, very unprecedented in history, as far as I know,
the outer planets have all moved, um,
have all made ingresses into new signs over the last two years.
Uh, Pluto made its ingress into Aquarius,
uh, which is traditionally associated with, um,
crusades and religious wars.
Most people don't understand that, but it is, um, Neptune and made its ingress into Aries.
And that's what a lot of people are waiting for.
That happened during the civil war.
Um, and so a lot of people who've been concerned about civil war breaking out in the U S
were very concerned about that moment in March when Neptune made its ingress into, um, Aries,
which is also, um, a transit that's about crusades.
And when we talk about crusades, we're not just talking about crusades against, um, Islam,
you know, the West versus Islam.
We're talking about just religious crusades in general.
So for instance, if you had a conflict between the West and Orthodox culture or, uh, the West
and, uh, East Asian culture, those would be something that would, that past historians would
look at as religious crusades, or whether they have a secular basis from our modern understanding
or not.
Uh, however, Uranus has to move into Gemini Uranus in, um,
Uranus in Gemini is, um, a bifurcating aspect.
It is, uh, it is a time when there is a sudden and marked division when people take sides.
So we saw that in, uh, we saw that in the revolution.
We saw that in world war two, this Uranus in Gemini is the crisis aspect that generation
theory talks about the fourth turning.
That's the, the, the, the culmination of the fourth turning is, is Uranus entering Gemini.
Uh, we saw in world war two and really people who've been making these predictions of like
a, of an imminent civil war.
It wasn't possible, uh, from an astrological perspective until Uranus, uh, made its ingress
into Gemini, which it will on the seventh, I believe of July.
So after that point, uh, then what you would see is what happened in world war two, where
the world divides into two camps and communication ends between the two camps.
And you'll see what happened in the civil war, where nations divided into two camps and communication
sort of ends between those two camps where you see that like stark division, a division
that lasts for years.
Um, what we've seen so far in the U S and globally is, uh, just sort of a foreshadowing of the extent
of the division going forward based on the astrology.
Um, so the war is a lot more advanced than people think, right?
So we think like escalate to world war three, escalate to world war three.
And it's because we're, we've been trained not to think of this as a holistic conflict and like
conflicts in general, right?
The average person is trained not to look at them as part of like a geopolitical chess board.
So when we look at this, this, this conflict in the Ukraine or Ukraine, I don't like, I don't
like to call it the Ukraine anymore.
When we look at the conflict in Ukraine, then we start looking around the world and we see
other conflicts.
For instance, the conflict in East Africa, we see American mercenaries and we see Russian
mercenaries fighting in East Africa.
So traditionally they would have called that another front.
We don't call that another front because we'll, it's mercenaries fighting there.
The Mideast war with Israel, Israel is a U S proxy state.
Iran is a Russian proxy state.
And what's that one in Yemen, right?
The Houthis, those are all proxies for Iran who are proxies for Russia.
So it's, it's a proxy war.
It's not disconnected, right?
October 7th.
And it was October 7th, right?
Yeah.
That's Putin's birthday.
And no one really talked about the fact that they, they launched their attack on Putin's
birthday.
So that's kind of how the Russians, that's kind of a game they play.
They like doing that with the dates, as we've seen in other, other crises.
It's like their, their trademark, their signature.
So the Mideast war, and I'm not, I'm not being political.
I'm not siding with one side or the other.
It's terrible.
What's happening there.
I'm not saying it's, I'm not trying to redeem it in any way.
I'm just saying it's a front, right?
And so it was, it was going to spread to Syria.
It was going to spread to Iran.
It did spread to Syria.
We're in another proxy group, right?
The ISIS related militants who are a proxy group for Israel and Turkey, who are proxies for
the US, like suddenly took down the Syrian government.
That was going to happen.
Like there was going to be a, a fight there and now it's heading to Iran.
So why, why is this thing with Iran going on?
The most important thing, the first and most important, um, event in a, in a confrontation
between the East and the West is an invasion of the Middle East.
And the reason is Europe does not have any, or has very, very little, um, in the way of fossil
fuel reserves.
It is this great irony.
They had the North sea that they've drained most of the North sea.
But other than that, the great irony of, of Western Europe is they were in a great shape
historically to fight everyone.
But as soon as fossil fuels rolled around, they are in a terrible shape to fight anybody.
We talk about in this country, like how Europe doesn't pull their weight, um, in NATO.
Well, you know, the thing about that is everyone is known since the Germans collapsed because
their lack of fossil fuels and Europe can't, can't really fight anyone.
And they talk about like, well, what happens if the Germans start their own army and they
become this globe superpower?
They can't, they can't do it.
It's not possible.
They don't have the fossil fuel reserves.
They are entirely dependent on the Middle East or Russia.
So, uh, in the event of a, of a conflict between the Russians and Chinese and the West, the first
thing that has to happen is, um, the Mid-East has to be secured or shut down depending on what
side you're talking about.
Because once the Mid-East is shut down, the Europeans have about 30 days of fuel reserves.
And after that, they're unable to fight any conflict with anyone in any way, shape or form.
And they can maybe defend their homes, uh, but they can't stage any type of, um, any type
of, of war or anything like that.
Um, so when you think of like, well, why is the West involved in the Mid-East?
Like, why are we obsessed?
Why do we have bases in every country in the Middle East, but Iran?
Why have we fought, you know, the Iran, the Iraq war one, the Iraq war two, why do we, you
know, why do we constantly get into bed with these highly questionable individuals?
It all comes down to the securing NATO and securing Europe, um, by controlling the oil
flows and assuring that we're able to get that oil to the Europeans.
We can't, I mean, American can pump oil, but we really can't in wartime send the oil they
need via boat over to Europe to keep their, um, to keep their soldiers fighting, to keep
their tanks rolling.
Uh, so historically the Russians, the first thing they were going to do, um, at the outset
of a war was send a tank column down, uh, back when they could send tank columns that
we're going to send a tank column down into the Mid-East and try to cut off that
oil supply.
And even 30 years ago, right?
Mid-East was, there were mostly Russian client states.
The, the U S client states were in the minority, but we've been working to reverse that situation
for years and years and years.
And we have, they had Syria and Iran left and they lost Syria where they have their naval
base in the Mediterranean.
I don't think they've been kicked out yet.
Uh, however, they're, they're going to lose it right.
In the case of a war, they no longer have a stable, um, naval base.
They don't have a government to protect the naval base there.
So that is why the Iran war was inevitable because as tensions ratchet up between the East and
the West and Russia and NATO and, and China is a special case.
We'll talk about that.
Um, as that was happening, um, you have to deal with the Iran situation so that you don't
have a force capable of shutting off that oil flow to Europe, which is what Iran would do.
That was their job, close the Straits of Hormuz to anyone, but Chinese shipping and, uh, attack
the pipelines and stop the flow of, uh, oil into Europe.
So it was, it was inevitable.
It was going to happen.
So the astrology is really about telling us when it was going to happen in this case.
Um, that was in there, in the, uh, various remote viewing scenarios and data, particularly
the data from the Josh Maitland, uh, remote viewing with, with Dan Waits, uh, he, he was
pretty adamant that he thought that the data suggested, um, conflict between Israel and Iran.
So we weren't surprised when this happened.
Um, what the astrology and the remote viewing, like his astrology and his remote viewing would
tend to suggest is this is likely to flare up again in August and become a real issue.
And I think that common sense shows that that's probably true.
Uh, if it's not in, if it's not in Iran, it will be someplace else.
Um, the, the basic Russian playbook for.
Uh, uh, a military conflict between East and West includes, and the Chinese as well, but
they have a little bit different strategy.
The basic Russian playbook has a escalatory ladder.
And there are events that would happen prior to like the missiles flying, right?
Which is another story entirely.
But, you know, the Americans particularly propagandized into the belief that what world war three is, uh, two countries yell at each other until they get really angry.
And then they take a giant dump on each other by firing off all their missiles.
And then it ends.
The war's over.
Everyone goes home.
And, uh, you know, and society collapses and there's nuclear winter.
And that's not really how nations look at fighting these wars.
I'm a big surprise, right?
They have a very different idea of how these wars will go.
However, it's in everyone's interest for the public to have the idea that we do.
Um, so we don't think, think critically about these issues.
We don't even examine these issues.
We just sort of leave them alone to do their, do their thing.
Um, so nations consider like world war three to be winnable.
They do.
They consider the use of nuclear weapons to be something that can lead to a winner.
Uh, not a lose, lose situation.
Um, they don't believe the world will be as polluted as.
The common people believe it will be.
The general populace believes that it will be following a world war.
Uh, we're afraid of nuclear winter.
However, uh, Carl Sagan worked on that with that group.
Um, so that's what really sort of made it so famous.
Uh, the people who calculated the, the, the nuclear winter during Gulf War one, uh, Saddam Hussein
set a bunch of oil wells on fire when he was leaving Kuwait.
And the same math that said that we're, there was going to be this nuclear winter said that Saddam Hussein
would initiate a nuclear winter by setting all the wells on fire.
And that was, it was his doomsday weapon.
Like some knew about those calculations and wanted to set all the wells on fire to cause
a, a, uh, a winter, um, outside the Middle East across Europe and America to, uh, punish
us for, um, for the war.
And of course it didn't happen.
So the militaries, the world don't really believe nuclear winter will happen.
Now that doesn't mean it won't, but I'm just saying they don't believe these, these things
that regular people believe.
Um, they also don't like look at it as, you know, we're going to argue and then we're going
to just drop all our missiles.
That's not how it will happen.
Particularly because like at a time like this, right, Russia has invaded the Ukraine.
So we're on guard.
So a first strike is always something to be concerned about.
However, is it more or less likely there'll be a random first strike if they're already
fighting a war with the West?
Well, it's, it's a lot less likely because we're on guard, right?
Or our, our forces are probably active and that's classified information, but we can assume
they are, um, so when we look at like how things might escalate, then this is, this is
important.
I know it seems like a rambling direction, but it's not, um, what would happen prior to
a, a, a serious world war are things that we've become accustomed to seeing in the news
today, but that weren't part of our lives before 2020.
So, uh, Russian agents would attempt to start a civil war in the U S that's a fact.
That's, that's documented fact.
Uh, we hear people talking about civil war all the time, particularly people on, you know,
social media who may be bots.
They may be foreign propagandists.
It's arguable that it may not have been even possible to get to this point without foreign
propaganda.
Uh, it may not have ever been possible to divide the U S again, point of having a civil war without
the intervention of, of foreign forces.
And then foreign propagandists, uh, they would attempt to start a race war.
That is also on that list.
Um, interestingly enough, uh, person could argue that while the grievances are very valid,
um, or not depending on your political position, how you feel about the grievances that people
feel, uh, it is, it is clearly a fact that foreign propagandists and foreign agents were
responsible for attempting to create racial conflict in the U S over the last four years,
five years.
Um, for instance, black lives matter, um, at least one of the founders, I think a few of them
trained with communist, um, organizers in Venezuela when people tied to, you know, tied to the,
not maybe not directly, but it's, you know, Venezuela is again, another Russian public state.
So, uh, another, uh, rung of the escalatory ladder would be a depression and they've been
trying, God knows someone's been trying to plunge us into a depression.
Uh, a conflict would be fomented between the West and North Korea, Iran, Iraq, and Syria.
Uh, the neocons who organized the invasion of the middle East knew about this.
Like I said, this was used to be public knowledge from the defective literature.
So, you know, people who would make us policy always knew that prior to a, a world war, um,
the Eastern axis or the Russians and allies would attempt to formulate wars between the U S
and North Korea, Iran, Iraq, and Syria, uh, probably amongst others.
Uh, the Chinese call this the four war doctrine.
Um, I don't think the Russians have a name for it, but the concept is to tie NATO down with as many
wars as possible so that we don't have the physical ability to fight, uh, when, and if the war
escalates and trying to, and Russia actively become involved from that perspective.
Our actions make a lot of sense because we've been neutralizing these, um, these potential
wars prior to them happening one at a time, uh, until the point where we're stuck with this
Iran situation, which would be sort of the last, right?
Although North Korea, he agitates every once in a while, but I don't know, Trump did a pretty
good job of neutralizing him during the first administration.
I'm not saying I'm not making a positive case for Trump or a negative case.
I'm just saying, you know, operationally speaking.
So, um, we've had the attempted beginning of race war.
We've had the attempted beginning of a civil war.
Neither of those were popular, were possible, excuse me.
They weren't popular, but they also weren't possible before Uranus enters Gemini.
So I don't think that those two themes are in the past.
I don't think that those efforts were defeated.
I think they were or stalled or delayed.
So those are both things that if we continue to escalate towards war, those are items on
the escalatory ladder that you would see that would indicate that we're getting closer to
an actual out and out war with between the East and the West.
We would see an attempt to form a race war in the U.S. again, an attempt to form a civil
war in the U.S. again.
We see an economic crash if they're capable of doing it.
They've tried.
They've been stopped so far, but it is possible that that will be the case.
And the sudden onset of a depression, the Iran war will flare up again.
I think the others have been neutralized, but it's possible North Korea could become an
issue.
I know there's some remote viewing data going back years that would back up that North Korea
will become a hot war prior to the escalation to a full war.
Again, every remote viewer who looks into this sees the strong possibility of this escalation.
Any competent astrologer knows the astrology backs it up.
There have been prophecies and predictions going back thousands of years.
The Old Testament is full of prophecies of nuclear war.
If you read it, you actually read what they say.
There have been, you know, prophecies in other religions.
I mean, nothing is sort of more attested to in speculative or prognosticator circles than
the possibility of the escalation of this crisis.
But the normalcy bias kicks in, right?
And everyone goes back to what they were doing.
So the next thing, and this is kind of interesting, but immediately prior to the outbreak of the
war between East and West, it is predicted that the Russians and their allies would dump all
of their compromising information on Western politicians, political leaders, on Western
billionaires, et cetera.
So if you've been watching and following the news for the last few years, and they've been
talking about individuals having, you know, or lists of compromising individuals or information
about individuals, and why hasn't this list been disclosed?
Why hasn't that information been disclosed?
You know, I'm not saying it's tied to Jeffrey Epstein.
I'm going to say that Robert Maxwell, Ghislaine Maxwell's father, was a known Russian agent.
No one exactly knows who Epstein was working for because on that level, the operational level,
they're sort of mobile weaponized chaos autists.
They kind of work for everyone as a general, like, you know, that's generally just how their
profession works.
They sort of work for everyone and take money for everyone.
Who knows ultimately who their ultimate employer is?
However, like, we know that large amounts of compromising information is being withheld from the public,
and we tend to think of it as a bad thing.
I'm not saying it's a good thing.
What I'm saying is the disclosure of that information is part of an escalatory ladder
involved in fighting a world war.
So, from that perspective, it's kind of, you know, not the worst thing in the world that
it hasn't all been released yet, because if it all does get dumped out, that could represent
an imminent escalation of the conflict.
That's all I'm saying.
I hope I said that the right way.
I don't support anything that those individuals did, and I'm glad that they're going to jail.
I think they should all go to jail.
So, we've got the astrology.
So, and we're going to talk to Morgan about, like, what his stuff says.
I'm just trying to lay the, like, my opening rambling monologue to lay out the information
that people need to understand what the information says.
So, nuclear war in general.
First of all, we don't know what weapons foreign countries have.
We don't know what weapons we have, right?
We have to assume that we have weapons beyond nuclear weapons.
We have to assume that other nations have weapons beyond nuclear weapons as well.
We discount the Russians.
We've been doing that since the end of the Cold War.
However, the Russians in the Soviet Union were very technologically advanced.
But they didn't have a society that was really geared towards mass production.
So, people didn't really see any benefits from that technology.
However, it is quite possible that Russia has weapons that we're not aware of.
Or maybe we are aware of and we don't talk about.
But when people get this false sense of security, oh, well, the U.S. is, you know, 100 years in advance of what we've heard.
Therefore, we don't have to worry about the Russians or the Chinese.
That's not logical.
That's not valid reasoning.
It's based on presuppositions and cognitive biases.
We have to assume that they have weapons.
And also, whereas you and I don't, like those of us here, we don't hopefully spend time thinking about ways to destroy other people.
Hopefully, there are no psychopaths here.
If you are here and you're a psychopath, then that's fine.
But psychopathic individuals are able to come up with ways to attack and harm other people that make no sense to the rest of us.
They're able to think in a way that the rest of us are not capable of thinking.
So, those people who do design weapons as their business, right, they can think of things that we probably can't even imagine.
And that's going to come up.
That's going to come up because the remote viewing data, as well as the historical remote viewing data and the prophetic data and even the astrology,
suggests that at some point during this conflict, should it happen, let's hope to God it doesn't, but should it happen,
water will be used as a weapon, specifically flooding.
And that is something that we wouldn't think of, right?
We have these, like, missiles and missile countermeasures and then missiles designed to avoid countermeasures.
But then someone said, hey, what if we set off a bomb under the ocean?
Well, how can you possibly have a countermeasure for a radioactive tsunami, right?
And specifically, the people that said this were the Russians, who designed what the West calls a Poseidon drone.
They have their own name for it.
That's not Poseidon drone.
And they've been threatening from the beginning of the war with Ukraine to set off nuclear weapons in this Irish Sea and off the coast of Western Europe.
I don't know if they've threatened us directly, but of course, the weapons were designed to be used on us.
And they would set them off off the coast and they would create radioactive tsunamis.
And the tsunamis themselves, the tsunamis would be more radioactive than the use of a nuclear weapon because of the salt in the water.
The salt would form radioactive sodium isotopes that it's called salting and the half-life is about 90 days.
So the concept would be that wherever these radioactive tsunamis went, there would be this nuclear desert.
This is real, like, Dr. Evil, Dr. No, James Bond, supervillain shit.
But unfortunately, this is the world that we're in right now.
And this is something that shows up in the data as a possibility.
However, they do have these missiles.
And whatever else they have, they have these missiles, right?
But people don't understand how the missiles are used.
And because people don't understand how the missiles are used, then they think that they can't be used.
Because if they're used, it's going to create this fallout, this nuclear winter.
The missiles are a lot more advanced than they were at first.
And they're not all set off in the same way.
So nuclear fallout is a concern.
It's also part of the weapon, right?
The weapon is designed to use the fallout.
However, the fear of fallout is a little exaggerated.
Because the way that one uses a nuclear weapon varies depending on the target one attacks.
And most people don't understand this.
I understand this is like a weird sort of tangential topic, but it's important to understand if you're thinking about nuclear war.
If you have a nuclear weapon, you can set it off high in the atmosphere and try to use an EMP attack.
You can set it off at ground level.
And if you set it off at ground level, that's where the fallout comes from.
But you would do that with certain types of targets.
For instance, runways.
You would want to destroy the runways, you would set the bomb off at ground level.
And hopefully, you know, tear up the runway.
So that would be a case where you'd have tons of fallout.
You can also set them off below ground.
If you set them off below ground in order to bunk or bust, right?
You have limited fallout from that and limited heat, limited force emerging from that underground weapon.
If you set them off at ground level, of course, you have the flash and you have the fireball and you have the force.
And some of these weapons are pretty big.
Some of these weapons, you know, they can smash your house 30 miles away.
They're not as big as people think.
I mean, not like 300 miles.
Like some people think you set one off and it's, you know, 300 miles is just obliterated.
No, but still 30 miles is pretty, that's pretty significant.
However, most of these weapons would be set off in airbursts.
They'd be set off a mile or less above, you know, possibly in some cases, a couple hundred yards, depending on the target.
And the reason that you do that is to create this downward thrust, right?
The force moves downward and it crushes everything.
For instance, if you were attacking a city, you know, which we hope will never happen, right?
They would be more likely to use airbursts than they would to set it off at ground level.
It has a wider area and it has less fallout.
A much less fallout.
So because of the way these modern weapons are designed and because most of them are used in the airbursts, the fallout is often exaggerated.
Which is also one of the reasons why people who, you know, work in that industry are more willing to imagine the use of nuclear weapons than regular people are.
Because they understand that a major, major exception to this is, of course, where they have to target our ICBMs.
Now, most people know this, but not everyone.
I don't mean to be patronizing, but the reason the ICBMs are where they are, the reason you put them in the areas where they put them in our case, Montana, Western Colorado, Northwestern Colorado, I think, but it's Western Colorado, certainly.
Um, and the Dakotas.
So the reason that you put them there, well, one, they're away from the regular public.
So that's the first thing is you're going to try to put them in rural areas.
And I'm sorry, I'm having some problems here with one of my animals.
You try to put them in, in rural areas, um, keep them away from the public, but also, um, you put them in those areas because, uh, when the nuclear weapon goes off underground,
uh, or at ground level in an area like that, it, uh, it kicks up a lot of dirt and that dirt, of course, radioactive fallout.
Uh, but in that case, it's part of the design feature of having them there.
Because when you kick this sand up into the air, um, it, it, it's, it's up in the air for about 30 minutes, 15, 30 minutes.
And while it's up there, uh, you're about a mile up in the air, two miles, uh, you can shoot a missile up out of it and without much problems.
But when a missile comes inward, it's moving so quickly that when it hits that sand, that sand acts like a, like a force field.
As strange as that's going to sound, it sand blasts the incoming missile.
So, um, and it sets it off so you can fire out, but they have to wait about 30 minutes before they can fire back in.
And so what that does is in order to be certain that they've wiped out all the ICBMs, let's say 400, let's say we have 400 ICBMs in that area of like Northwestern, Colorado.
I don't know. I'm just making up a number. I don't have insider information.
Um, in order to take out those 400, in order to make sure that those are gone, they have to attack multiple times.
It's called the slow crawl.
They have to hit the site, hit the next site, hit the next site, and then they go back and they start again, half an hour later.
So they have to invest a lot of weapons in that isolated rural area in order to assure that they have destroyed our ability to use the weapons that we have there.
Uh, so that's part of the design feature as well.
That's also why if you're really concerned about fallout, you definitely absolutely do not want to be downwind.
of an ICBM field, right?
Because that's where the vast majority of the fallout is going to be.
That are, I would also not want to be in, in Texas, near Pantex, which is our, um, where we store our decommissioned nuclear weapons and the plutonium.
But those are two areas where you'd have like massive amounts of fallout.
Uh, it looks like we might've just lost Jake's key for a second here.
And it looks like I'm having an ICBM field.
Uh, you know, what I'm not supposed to say, uh, sorry that I was, uh, disconnected.
I think I, I maybe mentioned something that's public knowledge, but I guess not something I'm supposed to mention on, uh, in the space.
So I will, I will skip that, uh, going forward.
Uh, I'm not attempting to, first of all, I, I don't have any classified information and I am a friend of American national security.
I, I'm an American, so I want us to be as secure as possible.
And I absolutely do not want to, uh, accidentally disclose any information that I'm not supposed to know.
Um, but that was a mess like information.
So, uh, we good Morgan.
You there?
Was it all quiet while I was gone?
I just need to make sure anyone can hear me.
Hello.
Yeah.
You're coming through again now.
Okay, good.
Yeah.
No, I just, I made an error of judgment there.
Um, or, or it's just, you know, just a coincidence.
Let's just call it a coincidence.
Anyway.
So that, that is how those weapons are used.
And so if you're thinking about this information, you get concerned about your own personal situation.
You need to have, um, an idea of, you know, what you would personally be facing based on where that you live.
It may not be what you think it is.
And from the perspective of say, someone who doesn't want you to think about nuclear war, right?
It's, it's great if you either don't think about it at all or world war three, let's just say world war.
World war three, because it may not be nuclear, right?
It's, it's great if you, if you don't think about it at all, or if it's great, if you're overwhelmed and just throw your hands up and say, there's nothing you can do.
There are, there are three options in this case, right?
There's option one.
Don't, don't think about it.
You know, live your life and enjoy your life as much as possible.
Don't think about anything bad happening.
Uh, you know, be the, the grasshopper option two is, you know, go full ants and, and be a prepper.
And actually I'm not, I'm not a prepper.
Um, although I, I do think we should have some extra food and water on hand, et cetera.
Right.
But you know, you build your own bunker.
You want to keep everyone out.
It's very American.
You want to know like what is going on with our political process.
All you need to do is start talking about like how people think about nuclear war or world war.
Right.
You're like, there's an impending catastrophe.
What are you going to do?
Someone says, I believe it.
I'm going to, I'm going to build a place where no one can get to me.
Cause the first thing I want to make sure is that no one in my community can get to me and take anything I have.
The second thing I want to make sure is I have more than other people in my community.
The third thing I want to make sure is I can emerge from this and start a bit open a business or set up a, a feudal, a warlord state.
And then I'll take my, you know, I'll take all of my prepper stuff and I'll turn myself into a, a, a, a rich warlord or businessman.
It's very unique sort of worldview that we have from in this country.
And I guess in this culture, and it's not, by the way, it's not a good idea.
No one survives crises without community.
The, the, the, like three people in a building fighting off the zombie apocalypse is not, is not real.
It never has been real.
The fact that people immediately in a crisis, like, or when they think about this, want to protect their immediate nuclear family against everyone else shows how weak the bonds are in our society.
And there are reasons for that, but it's probably not better to get, not good to get into right now.
Um, but it's not, it's, it's not going to happen, right?
Survival is not making sure that you and two or three family members can live in a basement for three years.
It's, it's, it's making sure that you live in a community that's going to take care of each other to the best of their abilities.
There is no way to safeguard yourself against death.
We're all going to die at some point.
Um, you know, it's, it's trying to, trying to give yourself the best chance, but also trying to ensure the survival of your community, of your family, of your nation, et cetera.
Um, yeah, so that's, that's how it would happen.
Now, as we've talked about, like this, there are going to be wild cards.
There are going to be weapon systems that, um, we don't know about.
There are going to be, if, if it were to escalate to that point, there would be biological weapons.
We have seen how that would play out.
And, uh, there's nothing that's going to stop it from happening.
If that happens, um, these, these weapons systems.
They can also use chemical weapons.
Like, you know, um, ICBMs can be loaded with chemical weapons at that point.
You know, what's the difference, whether you're in an, you know, in an area attacked by a nuclear weapon or a chemical weapon.
Um, still the best solution is probably not to be like, if you're concerned about nuclear war, probably don't, you know, live under a significant target.
I mean, that would be like a, you know, um, intentional community is not a bad idea, but it shouldn't be intentional community as the response to the fear of nuclear war shouldn't, that shouldn't be necessary.
I think people should be particularly people who have an interest in these type of subjects should be thinking about being close to other people and developing relationships, relationships with other people who also have interest in these type of subjects.
Right.
Um, so I don't, I don't think that fear of war should have to really come into it, but it does because our society tells you that if you intentionally plan your life, if you like, right.
Like the thing that they're really afraid of, they're not afraid of the war, but they're afraid of like, what if 15 or 20 people like moved to the same spot and like lived in three houses next door to each other?
What if that, what if that, that could be a cult?
Oh my God, that could be a cult.
Isn't it, isn't it funny that that's our preoccupation?
We're not afraid of bombs landing on our heads, but we're, we're definitely afraid of the fact that there might be a house at the end of the street where people are weird.
It's just a fucked up, fucked up scenario.
Um, so Morgan, let's, uh, let's jump in with what you may have.
I know that you don't have everything prepared and that's why we're going to do a two-parter, but I, I know that one of the first, um, one of the first sessions that I noticed, uh, from you.
And I think I, I saw it in a Reddit post, although I don't frequent Reddit and we'll talk about that on Monday, um, was your post about Vladimir Putin.
Um, uh, sure.
So you are correct.
I have not had as much prep time as I had aimed for, but yeah, based on kind of going late the last few days, which is fine.
I mean, it's all, it's all good stuff.
Um, all enjoyable, all, you know, in a, in a certain sense, part of the community building thing that, that you were just talking about.
Um, but between that and, uh, I must just be getting acclimatized to the warmer weather.
That's really just kind of hit this last week.
Uh, I have not been sleeping well, basically all week.
So, you know, that's neither here nor there and it is what it is.
So, um, okay.
Um, what JT is referring to is a project that I managed for our remote viewing group.
Um, I guess this was back in 2022.
Um, so, you know what I think I might just do JT, let me know if you have any objections, but I think I might just read from the, uh, from the important section.
I, I don't, I don't object at all.
I think that's great.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Well, you know what, that's what I'll do here.
So, uh, we ran a project.
It, uh, well, I, I was the project manager.
Some of our guys were, uh, the viewers and, um, I wrote an article or a report based on our result.
So, it was a two-parter, um, the two targets that I had the guys work were, let's see, number one was something that we would call a deep mind probe.
And the second part was kind of the, uh, kind of complimentary to that.
It's something that we would call an uppermost thoughts exploration.
Now, if you think about it, um, these are both, uh, mental explorations designed to give us an idea of what is, well, in the case of a deep mind probe, what lies deep within the mind of, in this case, Vladimir Putin.
Uh, the uppermost thought target is designed, uh, pretty much as it sounds, to describe the, at least at that present time, the ideas that were foremost in, uh, Putin's mind.
Um, so, let's just go through it here.
So, results, part one, deep mind probe.
Uh, so again, I'm just reading from the report and I will actually, maybe I'll link it.
Uh, when I'm finished, I'll, I'll link it in the, uh, comments and I'll put it up in the, uh, in the nest.
All right.
So, part one, deep mind probe.
To better understand an individual's current thoughts and current and thought processes, one must first understand the underlying foundations of an individual's deep mind, which produces such thought patterns.
To this end, we have identified several concepts and characteristics, which could be categorized as follows.
One, framework.
Vladimir Putin operates within a deeply embedded and highly disciplined framework.
This is directly attributable to his history as a member of the Soviet and later Russian military, security, and intelligence services, notably KGB, FSB, and Russian armed forces.
This is Putin's strategic and, to a lesser degree, ideological home base, so to speak.
Less a playbook than a generally reliable frame of reference.
Nonetheless, this implies a relatively high degree of predictability.
Part two, motivation.
Putin is acting from a place of desperation.
Putin is acting from a place of desperation, a perceived state of having been backed into a corner.
In a word, trapped.
He feels a deep desire, if not a need, to correct for what he sees as past mistakes, which led to the weakening and eventual collapse of the Soviet Union,
and the subsequent difficulties Russia has encountered if in its efforts to rebuild.
From this perspective, he can be considered of sound mind and genuine conviction, solidifying his devotion to the cause.
Part three, goals.
During the execution of this deep mind probe, we identified the subject's deeply desired goals, which can be broadly summarized under two categories as follows.
A. Glory.
Despite any public statements to the contrary, territorial expansion is very much the objective behind Russia's recent activities.
Bearing in mind, this was conducted and written in 2022, at this point comparatively earlier on, in the ongoing, what do they call it, SMO, Special Military Operation, their activities in Ukraine.
The intention is to continue subsuming territory, gaining ground with expansive momentum as long as they are able.
There is also strong and repeated reference to the ideas of modernization and development.
Goal B is legacy.
Though we identified no sign of imminent fear for his own life, we did detect in the subject an acute awareness of his own mortality,
and the desire to leave behind a particular and meticulously crafted legacy.
Knowing his time and power, if not on this earth, is time limited, he wishes to be seen and ultimately remembered in a certain way.
This desire is perhaps best illustrated by the photographs we are shown of Putin, both on the job and outside of his official capacities.
A bare chested Putin riding horseback through the Russian wilderness, a judo match, a hockey game, all very archetypal, symbolic of strength, masculinity, and independence.
Putin, the strong and wise tactician, the great Russian who restored the land to its ideals.
Effectively, Putin wishes to be typecast in the annals of history as somewhat of a neo-Soviet reformer, or in a sense, a modern and good version of Lenin or Stalin.
Part 2, Uppermost Thoughts
Where a deep mind probe is designed to explore the subject's unconscious and subconscious thought, revealing one's modus operandi, this, of course, is only half the picture.
To complete our present understanding, we must also explore the flip side of the coin, Vladimir Putin's uppermost thought, or the most prevalent ideas at the forefront of his mind.
At present, Vladimir Putin is operating under tremendous pressure.
Much of the stress stems from the belief that he stands alone, that only now and only he can maneuver his country back to its former glory.
In this present era of post-COVID global reorganization, he views himself as uniquely positioned and suited for this task, an outlier, an infidel of sorts, a disbeliever in and opponent of the generally understood and accepted world order.
He also views the present situation as potentially late stage, racing toward the end game.
As Ukraine falls, the probability of their Western allies lashing out increases exponentially.
In the event of expanded hostilities, or the perception of any larger-scale conflict with the West, Putin is fully committed to the use of advanced weaponry, including nuclear, as a targeted and final injunction.
A veritable holocaust in but a moment.
This is his option of last resort, a decisive way out.
One that he does not wish for, but one that he absolutely will pursue if pressed beyond a certain point.
And that point is near, should his adversaries continue their perceived unwarranted interference.
It is important to understand that from his perspective, this would be considered a victory, an achievement of his goal, under the circumstances.
He thinks to himself, there's a Russian phrase here, sorry I don't know how to pronounce it, but the English translation is,
The day is coming, you bastards, he is not bluffing.
Of note, we identified the concept that his payload is intended for detonation over water, not land.
That's the body of the article.
Go ahead, JT.
No, that's the big one.
I'm glad you got to that, because that was going to be my question to point that out.
Yep.
So, you know, as I was pointing out, the Russian state media has threatened repeatedly to use nuclear weapons in the Irish Sea and in the ocean in general as a way of resolving these conflicts.
And we can only speculate, oh, fuck, okay, I'm going to try to avoid getting the jump button here.
There is nothing on Earth more classified than nuclear countermeasures.
There are people online who speculate about countermeasures for the use of nuclear weapons.
We should not assume that anyone has complete countermeasures in that, in that, we should not assume anyone has the ability to, to completely, we should not assume anyone has complete countermeasures against the use of nuclear weapons.
However, if there are, then you would see them designing weapons to avoid the countermeasures, and you would also see them trying to find them in new and novel ways.
There is no countermeasure to a raging flooding sea.
So it's sort of there from the Russian perspective, and I think just from the perspective of reason, that is sort of like the dollar, the buck stops here, right?
That's the final, the final recourse.
Now, during the Soviet Union, it was rumored that Stalin had, well, you know that, okay, so Russia has a dead man's switch.
They have a system, and it's actually a very big concern, because it's a system that's been around for more than 40 years.
A computer system that will launch the Russian missiles should Russia suffer a first strike, and should their leadership, should their leadership be destroyed.
So technically speaking, because of that system, um, you know, no one should really think about first strike on Russia.
Um, I'm not, I'm not challenging anyone's thoughts, of course.
I'm not in the, um, defense industry.
So whatever, uh, people think is a good thing.
However, like that's the, the, the intended goal there.
Now, supposedly during the Soviet Union, um, it is possible to make these weapons more dangerous by including certain other substances in the shell of the, the weapon itself.
It's called salting.
And what it does is create more dangerous, longer lasting fallout.
And it was alleged that Stalin had created weapons that, um, attached to the dead man's switch that had cobalt included in the design of the weapons.
Because the radioactive cobalt generated would have a half-life of 5,000 years, and the concept was that the, that the fallout itself would spread across the planet and wipe out life on Earth.
That's just fucking awful.
It's so fucking crazy.
Uh, the, the allegation was that Stalin had this, that he was going to threaten to wipe out life on Earth if anyone did anything to him.
Uh, there's no reason to believe those weapons exist or still exist, but I think that if they were something that was on the table, they would have come up in the data that Morgan, because Morgan's team did a real strong deep dive, right?
So it's, it's actually as crazy as this is going to sound, it's a positive thing that life-ending, world-ending weapons didn't come up in his data.
Because, you know, the Russian, Putin has said this, and other Russian leaders have said this, what, what do we need the world for if Russia is not in it?
Like, that is their position, right?
And that was clearly Stalin's position.
So it is, it is a positive sign that their doomsday weapon is a little bit less doomsday than their original doomsday weapon seems to have been.
So let's just say that.
All right, Morgan, I didn't try to, I didn't try to cut you off, I just wanted to explain about the Poseidon and what it meant.
If you have more stuff about Putin, by all means, because then we're going to switch to China.
Um, no, you know what, that's, that's the,
that's the body of the report right there.
So, uh, if anyone wants to read the whole thing, including, you know, the introduction and the, the conclusions and whatnot, uh, I've posted it, uh, as a reply into the nest.
Awesome.
And, and I, I think that we should poke intuitive underground stuff in the nest of every one of our presentations, even if it's tangential or doesn't seem directly related, because, you know, we want to make sure that people are, are paying attention to you guys' work.
Um, so the other thing that you want to pay attention to when it comes to assessing, making a personal assessment about the possibility of a global conflict, you want to look at China.
And the reason this is particularly important is that a lot of people don't realize that the Chinese and the Russians have fought wars against each other.
And I want to try to avoid the dump button here.
Um, the, the last time was in the sixties.
They had a border conflict and supposedly it was a full fledged war and just, it was just referred to as a border conflict.
So we really don't know.
That's the allegation that was made is that they, they fought a very serious war on the, on the Chinese Russian border.
Now the Chinese, um, believe that a large, stop me if you've heard this one before, this is sort of a thing.
They believe a large area of what is now Russia, uh, should belong to China.
And, you know, they got this whole thing, like historically, if there was ever any area that they influenced or were marginally in control of, therefore it's part of China and it should be part of China forever.
Uh, so in this case, Siberia, um, we think like no one would want to live in Siberia.
Actually, it seems that there are plenty of people who do because illegal Chinese immigration in Siberia is a huge concern for the Russians.
And there are so many, um, Chinese migrants in Siberia that it's widely understood that Siberia will eventually, uh, end up back with the Chinese.
If it ever was part of who knows, like there's a lot of, uh, interpretation that goes into history.
Right.
But, um, soon the majority of people in Siberia are going to be ethnic Chinese who were born in China.
And that there's a lot of tension between the Russians and the Chinese.
If you really, if you were in a position like a leader of Russia or China, right?
Like America is a huge concern, but ultimately your biggest concern would be that other culture right on your border.
There's so many differences between the Chinese culture and the Russian culture.
There's so much different history and they're both so powerful.
And Russia is, is experiencing a population collapse.
That's put it, puts it in a desperate situation, right?
As Morgan alluded to, uh, not only are they in a corner, uh, geopolitically, their population is imploding.
And it's quite possible that the Russians won't be able to fight a war in 30 years if they don't, um, reabsorb the former territories of the Soviet Union and get the ethnic Russians back.
Um, and the Chinese, they have a lot of people and they would sure like to park those people, some of them in Siberia.
So there's a, there's a sort of a natural tension there, right?
And what most people don't understand is no one knows, right?
We naturally think China and Russia allies, but they haven't been right.
They haven't been allies.
As far as we know, like there was a long period of time where they really weren't, but there's some questions like, was that real?
So that's why I say like, we don't really know about the Chinese Russian conflict because there are two schools of thought.
There's one school of thought, like Russia and China are always on the verge of almost going to war with each other.
And we just don't see it.
The other school of thought is no, Russia and China have always been together.
They've always been, um, they've always had secret plans to destroy the West.
And we just don't see that.
And depending on your own ideology and what you bring to the table, that's sort of how you decide what you think is true and what you think isn't true.
However, whereas we think of Chinese as like a Russian client state, the exact opposite is true.
Like if you take the five mile view and this is the part that I'm afraid I'm going to hit the dump button, um, China is a Western client state, right?
Like we, we think like, oh, well, China stole all our jobs, the outsourcing, like what did they, how could they possibly have done that?
The Chinese, the evil Chinese got together with Western business interests and they stole all our jobs.
Is that really what happened?
Historically, that's not what happened.
Historically, we sent the manufacturing to China intentionally.
Historically, we built the factories in China intentionally.
Now, why would you do that with a country that was your enemy?
Well, if people say, oh, well, that's, our leaders must be traders.
Except no, I mean, if you look back in the history of China, China has been a Western client since the Opium Wars, right?
We, we rescued the Chinese from the Japanese during World War II.
We occupied, or the West occupied, both U.S. and, and England occupied China in the 1900s for, for a lot of the 1900s.
Um, and China went to an isolationist period and then the West went in, opened up China again and built up China again for Western economic purposes.
I'm not saying the purposes were for the Chinese, but from a, a Russian standpoint, for instance, hypothetically, if you were somebody who was worked in the Russian intelligence, I don't know anything.
I'm not part of intelligence services.
I'm not Russian.
And I, you know, but this is just reason, right?
And this is sort of something we talked about publicly during the Cold War that people have forgotten about.
It sure as hell looks like the, the Chinese are pretty tight with the West.
The fact that they come out every once in a while and say, you know, oh, death to America or the long march, we're going to go past the three island chains and we're going to hit the U.S.
It could be true or it could be divide and conquer tactics, the same divide and conquer tactics we see from them.
So the Russians can't trust the Chinese or vice versa.
And they don't know.
Neither the Russians or the Chinese know if either of the other party has a secret deal with the West.
Or is under the West's control.
We say, well, Russia can't be.
Well, what happened in the 90s?
Right?
Like we look at Russia now.
Okay.
So the data suggests, yeah, we are close to a true war.
But if you look at Russia over the last 30 years, in the 90s, we went in and took control of Russian society.
You know, to a large degree.
So they can't tell, you know, if it's real or not.
If the Chinese are real, really against the West and if the West is really against the Chinese.
So it's called the, well, this is a poor name, but it's a name that was coined a long time ago.
The Scissors Strategy, right?
Where Russia and China seeming to appear independent of each other would sort of encircle the West.
And then at the last minute, they would come together in one unified front and fight World War III.
But since the Russians and Chinese cannot trust each other and do not know who is invested in the West to what extent.
They have to move in lockstep with each other.
So the times when you see like a genuine escalation.
You see an escalation between the West and Russia and the West and China.
So, we see like events occurring at certain points in time.
I'll give you an example of like one event that was a good sign.
Like when Russia invaded Ukraine, a lot of people were concerned.
Like, is this going to imminently lead to World War III?
Well, how do we know it wasn't going to imminently lead to World War III?
Because Russia, because China did not invade Taiwan.
If Russia invaded Ukraine and China invaded Taiwan, that would have been a clear sign that we were imminently facing a World War crisis, right?
Because they would have to move in lockstep with each other.
They have to demonstrate to each other that they're trustworthy, that they're in it together.
It is not beyond the realm of possibility that in the event of a World War, because this is what happened last time, right?
The original, when World War II started, the Germans and the Russians were allies.
So, just because you start a war doesn't mean you end the war together.
So, there's no way of predicting, if a World War were to start, who the Chinese would be with.
As crazy as that sounds, because we always think of the Chinese as enemies, we don't look at the reality of the situation.
Which is our economies are tied together, our companies are tied together, we're virtually the same.
The West and China is virtually the same on a corporate level.
So, the Russians have to be concerned about that.
Now, it just so happens that Morgan has data relating to the relationship between China and the West.
And it's interesting because I think it may touch on the drone situation a little bit from last year.
But it certainly gives us, like, notable data about what might be coming in the future.
That's your clue, your indication, Morgan.
That's time to talk about the Chinese data, if you have it.
Yeah, okay, now, I'm going to have to start this with a caveat.
So, the work that I had the guys run on the idea of U.S.-China relations,
what we were attempting to do was to monitor the trajectory, the path forward of these international relations.
By, well, we conducted an initial study, okay, we got a pretty clear picture of what the data said.
And what I did was I had the guys run the same target hidden behind a new set of target reference numbers,
basically once a year over the course of several years, just to kind of monitor the situation,
see if anything changes, really didn't appear, at least we didn't know any real significant changes
in our interpretation of the trajectory data.
None of this has been published on our website as yet,
largely in part due to the fact that a lot of the data that we came up with
was almost too specific for my own comfort in publishing.
You know, the last thing I would want to do would be to publish things that could potentially be considered,
you know, risks to national or international security.
And, you know, again, I don't want to come off as sounding all grandiose in that statement,
but some of the data was fairly specific.
And I just, none of us really were comfortable in publishing any of that data.
So I have a partially written, somewhat watered down report.
I'm not going to read directly from it.
I'm just going to, I'm just going to give you guys a moderately vague kind of overview of what our data describes.
I think the big picture, and this was identified fairly actually early on in our RV session work,
in using the technical remote viewing method, early in session,
what we do is we identify key aspects of the target in the form of what we would call archetypes,
visual archetypes.
So, you know, a mountain might appear as a basic peaked feature.
You know, a landscape would probably just be a flat line.
So, that sort of visual archetype, if you can see what I'm getting at there.
So, the primary visual archetype identified in almost all of these sessions,
it was very consistent, was a downward spiral motion.
So, that kind of says a lot right there.
The kind of, the big picture tells us that we expect
U.S.-China relations to deteriorate in time
to a near zero.
Internally, we've been discussing it in terms of a
near complete,
possibly a complete economic decoupling.
That's kind of the kind of language we've been using.
We do have indications, pretty specific indications of
pretty much all the kind of characteristics you would expect to see in that kind of a situation
or scenario.
Things that get into espionage, defection, sabotage.
And there is some pretty solid indication of
kinetic activities taking place.
And I think that's really all I want to say about that right now.
But that, it's all there.
I did not write down this name, and I should have.
But, you know, we, like I said, we can't say what is happening with China at any given time.
China is a very close society.
And from, like, the point of esoteric research, that is a real pain in the ass.
Because even just the language barrier is so significant that China has thousands of years of records.
A lot of it is some pretty whacked out stuff.
Like stuff that we'd be into, but we can't access it because we don't speak Mandarin or Cantonese or
whatever dialect the records are written in.
And it's not something you can quickly learn.
There was a letter published around 2008.
There was a speech given by a Chinese general.
And I think it was Chai Ho Tan, but I'm not sure if that was his actual name.
And he outlined the use of a biological weapon against the United States at some point in the future
with the intention of depopulating 100 million or more Americans in the event of a conflict.
Now, the reason that's important, I mean, obviously, it's important in space, right?
But the reason that's important is that we often look at, like, events.
And we think of, like, superficially, even when we think we're being, like, really deep about it, right?
So we say, like, oh, well, what happened with this virus?
And, you know, was it?
I think everyone knows now.
I'm sure there are still some pulldowns.
We all know it was the Wuhan lab.
But we also know that Americans were involved, right?
That we were the ones who sent the virus to China, to the Wuhan lab, right?
That's public record now.
They don't hit the dump button because that's out there.
That's not a conspiracy theory.
We know that.
So when you see something like that leak, right, you say, well, that was, like, the absolute worst scenario.
Or, like, that was an attack.
I've seen RV data that I don't think it shows that it was an attack, necessarily.
However, you know, once it was released, it certainly, you know, people were put on planes and flown to the United States.
So things could have gone really south.
If you remember correctly, like, the leaders of all the nations aligned with Russia and China went into bunkers for a year after COVID started.
And ostensibly, it was because they were hiding from COVID.
But, of course, you don't really want to be in a bunker hiding from COVID or a biologue because once it gets in there, you know, you're in trouble.
So that wasn't the real reason, more than likely.
The real reason was no one knew how the U.S. was going to respond to the situation.
Or the Russians and the Chinese were going to respond to the situation.
And everyone went into continuity of government mode, more than likely.
We can speculate.
And the fact that all of our known enemies were in bunkers at the same time, that sort of gives us some idea, like, where everyone's head was at.
However, had that not occurred, had COVID not occurred, now, we talk a lot about COVID, Morgan and I.
Both COVID and the vaccines, right?
And I don't want to get, like, break this and turn this into a conflict about that.
But, you know, there is the same pathogen in both.
So we tend to get divided as a society and say, well, you know, are you concerned about COVID or are you concerned about the vaccines?
And, you know, no one, there's really no third poll where people say, I'm concerned about spike proteins, right?
Okay.
So it could be a bigger problem than we have come to the conclusion that it is, right?
We talk about, like, we talk about infections, for instance, HIV, where you have a flu-like illness as the acute infection and then HIV as the chronic infection.
So we really can't say what is going to come of COVID, even though we all think we can now.
We really can't.
We're only going to know after about 20 years how long the real damage is and how severe whatever it was, the COVID virus, I guess we know what it was, that was released was.
However, that release may have forestalled something else happening.
We can't say for sure, right?
Things that didn't happen that aren't real.
But hypothetically, that is something that was talked about in Chinese circles as being, you know, a part of a war plan against the United States.
We all forget that the virus was conveniently released following the initiation of the trade war between Trump and China, where, like, our media was saying that, you know, America was suffering and China was doing fine.
But that's not what the evidence suggests.
The evidence suggests that the trade war was really having a negative effect.
And so trade war, we use that term metaphorically, they may not have seen it in the same way, right?
And if you study warfare, you know that wars are often trade disputes taken to the extreme, right?
That's cause of what said that.
So we don't really know if what China was working on at that time was what they were talking about, or if they were talking about something else.
However, we do overestimate, right?
We need, Jesus, I don't want to get in trouble here.
Okay, so we, right?
Like, when you shape popular opinion, you definitely change the way you represent the players, right?
So during the, prior to the collapse of the Soviet Union, we were led to believe the Soviet Union was invincible.
Today, we're led to believe the Chinese are invincible.
However, China has a very real problem.
It's the same problem that Europe has.
China is the Europe of the eastern axis, right?
They don't have fossil fuels.
And they are also heavily reliant, almost entirely reliant on the fossil fuels from the Middle East.
I'm sure they get some from Russia, but they need those fossil fuels.
And they also need Western trade.
And specifically, right, right now we're fighting with the Iranians, or not, but we're probably going to go back to fighting with the Iranians.
And Strait of Hormuz, right, that's 13% of the Chinese, the total oil the Chinese consume every year goes to the Strait of Hormuz.
And that's not including other areas from the Middle East that send them fossil fuels.
The vast majority of their fossil fuels come from the Middle East.
So historically, right, America, Russia would try to shut off the Middle East to cut off the flow of oil to Europe.
Now, America could also attempt to control the Middle East to shut off the flow of oil to the Chinese.
At the same time, India, who hopefully we're on good terms with, we hope, would shut down the Straits of Malacca in Indonesia and shut off Chinese trade.
So the spiral that Morgan is talking about in our relationship and cessation of trade, right, that is a nightmare for us because that's how we afford our lives.
People can say whatever they want about outsourcing, but that outsourcing was deflationary and allowed us to live very, very prosperous lives over the last 30 years.
Much more prosperous than any point in human history.
And that was related to the outsource of China.
So we need that stuff, right?
Whenever they talk about we're going to shut off the stuff coming from China, you're going to be in deep shit.
Because, you know, the fact that America can make something doesn't mean America can make it affordably for an American family.
All right.
At the same time, we're their business.
There is no other customer for the Chinese.
There is no customer that can replace us.
All right.
And they need that oil.
So if you shut off trade between the U.S. and China, the U.S. is in deep shit.
The Chinese are in war.
And that's what people don't understand.
And so we get into the situation where these, like, trade wars, and I'm not critical, I'm not criticizing anyone, but you're talking about an escalatory behavior, right?
You're talking about a, we'll show you how it would feel if this situation got worse behavior.
And, yeah, I think what Morgan's data shows is that's going to continue.
I think that trade will continue to be an issue, will become worse.
But in order for it to go to zero like that, in order for us to economically decouple, that would tend to indicate the shutdown of those straits, the shutdown of that transformation.
And at that point, you are in, like, Morgan's talking about, well, it could get kinetic.
Well, at that point, you're in a use it or lose it situation, right?
So a lot of, like, thinking about World War III is thinking about use it or lose it.
It's having geopolitical circumstances put a country into a position where they can either attack or forfeit their ability to attack in the future.
That's one of the reasons why an exchange of nuclear weapons would be so dangerous, because once you start using them, then you risk the potential of losing them the next day unless you use them all.
And it makes hypothetically controlling that escalatory scenario very difficult.
Very difficult for any country.
And, you know, it's not a moral thing.
It's just it's reason.
Right.
So we're going to do this as a two parter and we're going to break this up.
And next Thursday is going to be thinking about the end of the world where we'll talk more about the other aspect of this, because there is a lot of information in the data which tends to associate the escalation of war.
And this is not just our data.
But it's all the data and particularly an RV data has been showing up for almost 30 years.
The escalation of a global conflict with correlating it with a natural crisis.
Some of the data shows that it's coincidental.
Other data shows that perhaps the motivation for having the crisis, the war, could relate to preparation for the natural event.
And it's something I think when I listen to people talk about, like the pole shift.
It's all like all other things being equal conversation.
So it's like all other things being equal, you know, we'll be there.
What day are we going to see the pole shift?
Because I'm going to be, you know, mowing my lawn and I'm going to be going to my job and, you know, eating nice food at a restaurant.
And the next day there's going to be the pole shift.
And that is not a likely scenario.
Because the...
Hold on.
Morgan, someone's requesting bump them up.
Oh, Doomer.
Oh, Doomer, can you just give me a couple minutes before you doom out on us?
Well, Morgan can kick you up, but just give me a couple minutes to finish my stream of thought here.
So that is not a likely scenario.
What is a likely scenario is policymakers and governments and organizations are going to know human beings turn on each other.
And they're going to know that following a natural disaster, a natural crisis, right?
Where'd he go?
Did he just bounce?
Okay.
I guess I offended Doomer.
He might have dropped.
I would imagine he'll be back in a minute.
That's okay.
If I piss him off, it's fine.
I piss everyone off.
Okay, there we go.
So, look, following a natural disaster, following a crisis, everyone is going to be fighting over very limited resources if this is real, right?
And so the chances that, right, at that point, what we see as moral and ethical are different than what a policymaker would see as moral and ethical.
So if you were talking about ensuring the survival of human beings, because that's what we tend to frame it, right?
People tend to say they're going to start thinking about the survival of humanity, so they're not going to be moral and ethical.
But in reality, from their perspective, some of them are bad dudes, some of them are probably not bad dudes, and they would believe that it would be immoral and unethical to set human beings up for a situation where they could sort of all turn on each other and implode.
So there is even a moral and ethical argument made at that point that if everyone is going out, the best thing to do would be to give human beings the best chance by, you know, making, by thinning the herd.
I'm not saying I agree with that.
I'm saying that that is an argument that could be made.
It's also an argument that has been made in print, in paper, going back hundreds of years, but particularly in the last 40 years or so, right, 40 or 50 years ago, talking about subjects like this.
So more than likely, and this is what the RV data would support, this is what astrology would support, prior to any type of event like a pole shift, right?
If you're going to see things like World War III, you're going to see an attempt to neutralize any potential adversary following the natural catastrophic event, whether that adversary would be mobs of deranged zombies that you have to deal with on an interpersonal level, or that adversary would be peer or close to peer nations overseas with weapons they could use following that event to neutralize you completely.
So you're in a, a use it or lose it situation.
And the ultimate use it or lose it situation is the concept of kill shot, a solar micro nova, a pole shift.
At that point, if you're a policymaker, you really have to start to think about, you know, the interest that you have in, in, in trying to neutralize threats before they come up.
Okay, Doomer, go ahead.
Hey, sorry, I had tech issues.
I couldn't hear you the first time it was on my end.
I love that you guys are getting into the game theory, mutually assured destruction dynamics.
I think these are often misrepresented.
You said, you know, following, let's just say a sort of natural cataclysmic event, you would have an escalation of like a World War III situation, according to game theory, assuming you're implying game theory there.
But wouldn't you also have that prior to such an event?
Correct.
That's what I was talking about.
I wasn't talking about following.
I was saying that the concern you would have would be being attacked when you're vulnerable.
Right.
And so, so game theory would, I mean, just the just basic game theory, not like, I'm not a mathematician, but certainly the prisoner's dilemma would factor into that.
Definitely.
Yeah, I think I think people, everybody needs to start thinking really deeply about game theory.
I think it's I think it's one of the most important things and you're right, like we're talking about complex Nash equilibria.
But everybody needs to understand the prisoner's dilemma at a really basic level and what it means, how game theory changes when everybody is practicing game theory, especially the people with nukes.
My question, my request for you for the next round is any kind of data you have or any thoughts you have or both on.
The NHI influence, especially specific species or races on how this nuclear game theory exchange plays out.
NHI have been correlated with, associated with, I would say causally implicated in all of our nuclear facilities, all of even our, what I know is that our nuclear protocols,
even as they played out in the Cold War, have NHI game theoretical considerations baked into them, meaning in situations where we would normally retaliate with maximal nuclear destruction,
suspecting an attack, an impending attack from Russia, we had to place protocols that also factored in NHI working off of our game theory,
assuming we would retaliate if we mistook something coming from Russia and we had to put in protocols to deal with deception coming from NHI in order to escalate nuclear conflict.
I think with people like Bledsoe, where the NHI are telling him, oh, don't worry, we won't allow any nuclear detonation to happen.
And the same vision telling Bledsoe, once after humanity doesn't, you know, learns a harsh lesson, simultaneously implying nuclear escalation.
I think, at least my request is, these are the conversations I'd love to hear the most.
And these are the things I have the least data on.
Like, what is the role of sentient plasma?
What is the role of all these NHI when it comes to nuclear escalation dynamics, especially?
Does that make sense?
Right.
I have some, briefly touch on that.
We don't have probably the type of data that you want, but I have Chris Bledsoe on my list.
So that should be something that comes up in a few minutes once we work through Morgan's data,
because he has further data in sessions that we're going to cover.
But Chris, Chris Bledsoe is on the list.
Thank you.
And I assume Chris Bledsoe and his orb babies, right?
Yeah.
I mean, just, you know, just before we, just, okay.
So the thing about NHI data is that, you know, I, of all people, I'm going to tell you that NHI data is real.
But we also know that a certain amount of NHI data is propaganda, our own propaganda, and a certain amount of NHI activity is foreign actors who like ourselves, right?
So, and the thing is that that's a, that's a known unknown.
We don't really know to what extent that, so it's hard to make those discernments.
Yeah, I'm not asking for a prediction.
Right, and what's your favorite thing of all time?
Space Nazis, right?
So there's also the possibility.
Oh, I didn't know that was my favorite thing.
So there's also like the third possibility of a breakaway human civilization, human beings, same genetics as us.
We're living amongst us 40 years ago or 100 years ago, who right now are sort of separated from us, who also have these weapons.
And that also factors into what possibly might be going on with these different groups.
But definitely we'll cover that.
I just wanted to cover a couple of other, a couple of other pieces of information with Morgan, if that's all right.
Yeah, yeah.
No, and I'll drop down.
I just wanted, like, whatever you guys have, because these orbs are showing up constantly in places of conflict, constantly around our nuclear facilities.
And now we have a battle or a war unfolding around nuclear facilities on the battlefield, and people are seeing the orbs everywhere, right?
So even if you guys don't have anything, that's fine.
But, you know, next session or whatever you have here, I'd love to know, because the messages we're getting channeled is specifically also about nuclear escalation.
Right, so you might have missed this earlier, so I'm just going to, like, go over it again, like this specific piece before we go back to Morgan.
First of all, I, right, everything for me is independent.
It's just my own reason and my own interest through the years.
I've never been connected to the American national security industry in any way, shape, or form.
I don't have any insider information.
I just pay attention.
That having been said, I can tell you with 100% certainty that there is no area more classified and no area you want to avoid talking about just because you won't get your information out, right, or you won't have accurate information.
But there is the most classified information on planet Earth are countermeasures to the use of nuclear weapons.
I won't even, I could articulate that a little bit better, but I won't, because it just could potentially cause problems, right?
So that is super, super classified information.
So what you are talking about, right, like, that's one of the areas where the question is very strong.
Like, are we talking about NHI or are we talking about something that's super, super classified that isn't NHI activity at all?
And there's a real question there, because we're never going to know.
And I don't think, I think that's one of the areas where if somebody was a legitimate whistleblower and they did come forward with accurate information about U.S. and NATO technology in that area, I don't think that they would live very long.
And I don't think anyone related to them would live very long.
And I'm not, in that case, when you're talking about the lives of 330 million Americans, I don't necessarily think that's as evil a thing as some of the other behaviors with whistleblowers.
Like, that is, that is something that all of our lives depend on every day, you know, based on the game theory.
So, but, but I do have something to say specifically about Chris Bledsoe, because it did come up in one of the videos that we referenced above.
Morgan, we had another situation, right?
Now, Dan isn't able to be with us today.
Dan had specific personal remote viewing related information about how cataclysms or catastrophes might play out in the United States.
I do remember talking to you once, and I believe that you indicated that there had been some remote viewing data involving an attack on New York City.
But I don't know where that data is.
And when I mentioned it to you, it doesn't come up.
And that may be something that's too specific that you don't want to talk about because of how specific it is.
And you want to be put in a vulnerable situation.
So if you have any information about that, that would be good.
However, I do know that you do have information about both the most likely catastrophic event over the West Coast.
And I know that you have information about the kill shot.
And I think that you're willing to talk about both of that, both of those information.
So I'd like to just cover that before we go over what other remote viewers have said and then get into the Chris Bledsoe thing.
Um, yes, let me just.
Okay, why don't we, before we actually get too much further from the China stuff, I actually have one quick kind of follow-up to that.
Um, so this was the, this was a follow-up target that I tasked to our team following the U.S.-China relations trajectory work.
And the targeting strategy I chose here was to target the next flashpoint on that trajectory between U.S. and China's relations.
And again, um, I've, I've, I've, uh, we haven't published any of this on our website as of yet.
Um, I've talked about it in kind of pretty loose terms, uh, a couple of times, uh, just in conversations on X.
Um, so I, I can reiterate that here.
Uh, I'm not going to go into, uh, I'm not going to go into, yeah, okay.
Yeah, I won't go into great detail, but what I can say is that we came up with some, some data that basically,
it basically showed us that at some point in time we expect to see advanced Chinese operated drones
operating flagrantly over the U.S., including military installations.
Now, this was all prior to the, uh, late 24, early 25, uh, drone, uh, you know, the, well,
they're now colloquially referred to as the New Jersey drones.
And when that started happening, that really caught my attention based on the data that we'd come up with previously.
As of right now, there is no publicly available information that tells us with any degree of certainty,
one way or another, what that was.
However, I did come across a remote viewing group out of Poland.
Uh, I believe it was Poland.
Um, these are guys that I, I don't personally know.
Um, I've, I've not seen them before, so I can't, I can't speak to their track record.
However, apparently they were tasked with looking into the source or the origin of at least some of these drone sightings
that we saw earlier this year.
And they reported that their results indicated Chinese operation.
So if that is to be believed, that might be part one of this flashpoint situation we've been,
we've been keeping an eye out for.
Now, the B component, which has not happened yet, indicates widespread public acknowledgement
of, of the fact that the Chinese are able to operate technologically inside of the US with virtual impunity.
That, so far, again, that's not been verified or acknowledged, but I am still open to the possibility,
if not probability, that what we saw earlier this year and late last year was exactly that.
So, if at some point in the future it is acknowledged and understood in a fairly broad manner
that at least some of those drone sightings were, were Chinese,
then that is a major tick mark, um, on the trajectory that we, uh, identified previously.
Can I ask you a question?
Are you familiar with the Sean Ryan show and, and how that information was revealed through the Sean Ryan show?
I'm aware of the show, I don't think I've ever watched it, but...
Okay, so there was, um, there was a, a guest of the show, or someone related to a guest of the show
who contacted Sean Ryan and told him, or sent him emails related to that information,
and that, that gentleman then set himself in his, um, his Tesla, um, van, or whatever those things are called.
Uh, okay, JT's having connection issues again, um, hmm, I'm guessing he'll be back momentarily.
Maybe, maybe not.
...has been revealed publicly, um, following a series of events, uh, in the United States.
It got some media attention, um, and then it was dropped from the media.
However, the information that those were believed to be, uh, Chinese drones was released, um, publicly.
Uh, I don't know if that fulfilled, necessarily, the extent that you were, um, and no, I didn't hang up on myself for dramatic effect.
I'm not pretending.
I'm not saying, I'm, it's not a coincidence.
I'm sure it's a coincidence, but, um, but I'm not, you know, I'm not confabulating.
Uh, so, yeah, so the deal with that is, right, before we get to the other RV information, is, um,
those drones, if, if they were Chinese, um, could, could have carried, whoever was flying those drones, U.S. or otherwise,
could carry weapons, and if you could get them into whoever it was, if they were foreign, and they were flying around New Jersey,
uh, and they were undetectable, or very undetectable, and they were very stealthy like that,
and they were moved very slowly, and very low to the ground, um, uh, fuck, I don't want to get dumped again,
uh, right, they could fly over the White House.
Okay, we got that out.
So, like I was saying early on, in the beginning of this, like, we, those of us who aren't psychopaths,
cannot imagine ways to harm others, or not, at least not very well, but psychopaths can,
and so, it's a, it is a red herring to say the U.S. is a hundred years more advanced than everyone else,
and therefore, we don't need to worry about these people, right, that's not real.
We may be a hundred years more advanced than everyone else.
We may be a hundred years more advanced than the Russians and the Chinese.
That doesn't mean that they can't think of a way to harm us that we haven't thought of.
Or that we don't have countermeasures to, right?
They're very intelligent people, very technological advanced, very powerful governments,
you know, with a lot of resources.
So, you have to always remember that there is no scenario where we are safe from a world war,
and safe from having things happen here in the United States from a world war.
So, that's, like, emerging technology.
We're talking about, like, well, what do the Russians have, what the Chinese have, we don't know.
But if they have, say, anti-gravity technology, right, didn't get dumped, then that would be a concern.
That would be a serious concern.
No matter how far more advanced our technology was than them.
I mean, this concern began with the spy balloons.
Because, you know, everyone was saying, well, the spy balloons were looking at our bases.
Sure.
They also could have been carrying something, right?
I mean, everyone was, when the public was like, well, why didn't they shoot it down over Ohio?
Well, the reason they didn't shoot it down over Ohio was because they didn't know what the hell was in it.
Right?
And you don't want to, you know, people watch too many video games and movies.
We're going to shoot down random flying objects that we don't know what the hell is in them over our atmosphere.
Okay?
So, obviously, they waited until they were over the ocean before they shot it down.
Which is what the correct thing to do would be, even if they were sending information back.
I will point out that what everyone seems to forget, because we're so far from the Cold War,
is that there is a strategic reason for doing what they did.
And that is to study the air currents.
And that information doesn't seem very important to the average person, but it is if you were worried about a war.
If you were planning to attack somebody or fight a war with them, that's the most important information you could have.
Because that would be information that we use to target your weapons.
To have the most significant effect on the enemy.
So, that balloon right there was another escalatory ladder.
And if Morgan is right, potentially, about the drones, then that would be another escalatory rung.
Following that drone incident, we did have a transition to power in the U.S.,
which we're led to believe is an organic, democratic transition to power.
With that, we did have a change in policy.
And that change in policy involved economically reducing China and other nations' ability to fund that type of research and their militaries through the use of tariffs.
So, that may be a coincidence.
It may not be a coincidence.
It may be part of that downward spiral that Morgan was talking about.
Like, we're in that cave, right?
We're in Plato's cave looking at the shadows on the wall.
Where we can only speculate how things relate to each other.
So, are we good to talk about the West Coast situation?
You know, we could.
I would probably prefer if we actually waited until Dan was available to join us.
If it's all the same to you.
If we need to go into it now, I can touch on it.
All right.
Well, I don't know if he's going to be available to join us.
I don't know if Thursday is going to work for him or not.
I can summarize.
And you guys can fill in more information at a future date.
So, it does seem that they have some information that it's possible there would be an EMP attack on the West Coast at some point.
Yeah.
Let me give just a real quick background.
Great.
It's actually kind of interesting the way that this data came about.
So, most of the time when we're working projects, Dan or I will act as project manager.
We'll come up with a target.
Something that we find maybe possibly interesting or important.
We'll set up that target and send it out to the rest of the team.
Do our data analysis and any further remote viewing as required.
And come to our conclusions based on that data.
And if we have the time, we'll release it as an article on our website.
We do have what we call a blind target pool, which is basically just a database of a whole bunch of targets that we've come up with and we kind of continually add to over years.
And on occasion, we'll draw from that target pool and so that we can all work as blind remote viewers rather than one of us participating only in the capacity of a project manager.
Now, at one point, we decided, okay, let's draw something out of the blind target pool.
That target was United States Western Region slash next disaster.
The first run through that target, the first run through that target was, it was okay, to be perfectly honest with everyone.
The results were a little bit noisier than we would typically like.
So we kind of, okay, well, here's a first pass.
Maybe we'll, maybe we'll come back to this at a later date, see what happens.
So, um, the following round, we decided, okay, you know what, let's just, uh, we'll keep drawing out of the blind pool.
Well, the very next target that came out was in fact a duplicate of the, that, that exact same targeting strategy, again, hidden behind a different set of target reference numbers.
So that in itself is very interesting and notable.
Um, Dan did some quick math.
At the time, and if I remember correctly, the odds of us drawing the same target out of our blind pool twice in a row was something like 64,000 to one.
So that in itself was kind of notable.
Okay, was there a reason this target came at us again immediately after?
Um, the second round, the results were actually a lot clearer, um, a lot more decipherable.
And that was where we started to come across data that, that pretty clearly shows some sort of an attack scenario.
Some place in the US Western region.
Now, I would tend to think that the way that's targeted, being as it encompassed the entire US Western region, I would tend to think that our results are probably talking about a situation that affects, at the very least, the entire US Western region.
And it can probably be fairly, and it can probably be fairly safely inferred that the boundaries would extend beyond that.
That was simply the scope of our queue, of our targeting strategy.
So, I'll leave it at that for right now.
I'm going to, I'm going to go over all of our data in more detail, which I simply have not had the opportunity to do at this point, as I would have liked.
So, I would rather save, um, rather than going by memory and perhaps misstating something, I do not want to do that.
So, I, I would be a lot more comfortable if I had a little more time, uh, and we maybe pick back up on this in, uh, part two.
Yeah, great.
So, part two will be on, um, will be, uh, Jesus, what day is today?
Saturday.
Thursday.
If you can familiarize yourself with it by then, that'd be awesome.
And we'll just split it up because there's, there's connections to, um, all this data, there are connections to natural events.
And it's difficult to ascertain sometimes whether the data predicts natural events or events that are made to look like natural events.
At the end of the day, there's no difference in, to the people who are experiencing the event.
What it does tell us though, is that like we're saying, there's a escalatory ladder for a conflict between nations.
There could be almost a crisis escalatory ladder, um, involved here where there's something, you know, for instance, Ed Dames and his kill shot, right?
Um, Morgan is a student of Ed Dames and I'm, I'm not, uh, I understand there's some controversy, but without getting into that controversy, like, you know, timing is very difficult in RV.
However, a lot of people have seen that kill shot data, right?
As, as has Morgan and, um, that, you know, that data has always suggested that there will be an event, uh, at the end of, um, a military crisis or maybe an event that ends, uh, a war, um, that is, is natural in origin.
It comes out of the sun and affects the earth in different ways.
Um, and as we've talked about, like, an imminent event could be a reason, right?
So I don't think that shows up in Morgan's data.
I mean, you could like, you could really read into it.
Um, however, you know, perhaps the Russians and Chinese are responding to different things.
Um, but does the U S government, yeah, we know for a fact that the U S government has concerns about this, this stuff, right?
Well, no one, we know that the U S government has remote viewers, right?
We know that, um, they, they had them first and we know they have access to all the information generated by remote viewers who don't work for the U S government in the United States.
Um, we also know that they have access to all kinds of information that the rest of the world would really love to have.
Um, so our own, uh, actions could be informed by the knowledge of some sort of event like this coming.
And because of that, we're going to like split it up and we're going to talk about like thinking about the end of the world in general, uh, would limit the conversation about American national security and world war three.
There was no intention here to disclose not all this information is publicly available on the internet.
There's no intention to disclose any type of classified information.
The intention is to give people an idea for making their own assessment when, and if this is an imminent situation, right?
Because like we talked about in the beginning, there's bury your head in the sand or, you know, focus on enjoying life.
Don't worry about crisis.
Then there's the other aspect, which is, you know, live your life focused on preparing for crises.
And then of course there are a number of problems with that, including the fact that you eventually have to worry about your neighbors and worry about your family.
And it, it, it, it, the bunker mentality probably isn't a viable long-term strategy outside of like what we believe is a culture, right?
And then there's the third, which is, you know, focus on building community and also be aware of what is happening in the world around you.
So that, you know, if we agree that it's unlikely there's going to be this sudden dump that no one expects, well, then how do we decide?
Like, how do we know if, if we're in imminent danger personally?
Well, I mean, if you have like some knowledge about how this works, how this is likely to work, then you can see the signs.
And hopefully you personally can make an assessment at a point and say, you know what, this is a time when I, uh, maybe I should take this seriously.
Or maybe your assessment is, no, I shouldn't take this seriously.
I should keep my life and doing what I'm doing.
Okay, that's fine.
But should you come to the, a reasonable knowledge-based assessment that there's an escalating crisis that could, you know, come to fruition in three or four days, something like that, a week or two, then you're going to want to take action.
And then it, then it is very rational and very reasonable to take action at that time.
It's not being an occultist, not being a conspiracy theorist, but it is if you don't have the information, right?
So that's what the, the point of, of breaking this down is so that anyone who has an interest can make a, a, a personal reasonable assessment of when it's time for them to take action, not to, to spread around a bunch of whatever.
And so anything that Morgan feels is too, like, specific, like, we got to honor and appreciate that.
Um, there are, there's other remote viewer information, right?
Available.
We have 30 years of information about the kill shot.
Uh, we have, um, numerous session videos from, uh, Farsight, uh, Courtney Brown.
And, um, you know, say what you will, there are people who criticize Courtney for a lot of things, but then there are the people who say, and this is going to something that's going to come up Monday.
There are people who say that Courtney is a grifter.
Courtney Brown is not a grifter.
100% not a grifter.
It's not possible.
Okay.
Now, Courtney Brown believes that he's on a messianic mission of some kind that by his own admission, uh, in different ways.
However, in order to accomplish that messianic mission, he has had to live a calorie restricted diet because he believes he has to extend his life in order to save humanity.
Okay.
So right there, like, that's a, that's a belief that, you know, that sort of throws a red flag up for most of us, but right.
A grifter doesn't starve themselves for 20 years or more as part of their grift.
And that's just not how the psychology of a grifter works.
They don't torture themselves and torment themselves, you know, to charge you $10 a month to access their website.
Okay.
And the man is a college professor.
He really doesn't need the, the $10 a month that that goes to funding his operation.
So, um, his, I don't trust Farsight, the, the Farsight institutes.
I don't trust their information related to UFOs.
I don't, I don't trust their information related to non-human intelligences.
I think it's very likely they're being deceived.
I do believe that they think that they're communicating with something.
And in a few weeks we will have, uh, remote viewer David Powell on, and he will talk about remote viewing their, um, one of their, uh, Farsight alien communication sessions or whatever.
And what the remote viewer saw when he did that, um, it does seem that they're in contact with some sort of non-human intelligence.
That doesn't mean that it's an honest non-human intelligence, right?
Um, so I don't trust that information reporting, but I do trust his remote viewers.
I do.
I, they're, I, I have followed it enough to know that timing is an issue in remote viewing.
You don't judge remote viewing data as successful or unsuccessful based on a time someone sticks to it.
I mean, Morgan and I can fix that, but it's going to take a while, right?
With Astor Harvey.
But as of right now, you don't, that's not how you judge it.
You judge it by whether the events come to pass.
Because oftentimes it's like a cause and effect, right?
Oftentimes they can be viewing the beginning of a stage of related incidents that you can't time when that last incident is going to be.
And then that actually comes up specifically in, in, in some of these, um, some of these sessions.
So we put in the nest, we put links to videos from Courtney Brown recently.
Um, I had, I had sniped at him, uh, for some years for concealing data related to nuclear war.
I don't think he was doing it to be a bad person.
I think that he has, um, he has a little bit of that mentality that focusing on something causes it to happen, which isn't real.
That's not, that's not how reality works, but it's part of our modern American interpretation of reality, magical thinking.
Um, but he's got a little bit of that, I think in my opinion, and he and Aziz did not want to put out that information, um, and manifest it or whatever.
But they, they have a Farsight Prime and Future Forecasting Group.
Both of them have had information specific to the escalation of World War III for at least three years, because I follow them.
Um, and they did not put it out.
And I was sniping online in the comments section, like all the other cranks and weirdos, but probably the most cranky weirdo of them all, you know, telling them that they needed to put that information out.
Um, they have, um, uh, Farsight has put out a video about, uh, recently again, according to Brown, how to survive World War III, which gives them like very common sense, low investment prepper ideas.
Um, and I think that's, it's notable and it's to his credit that he put out that video.
They have recently put out half a dozen to a dozen videos related to the escalation of war in Europe and how that might happen.
The, they're putting out some videos related to Iran and they put out some of those half a dozen videos were like earlier videos on civil conflict inside the United States.
As we have talked about the U S naturally is not going to end up in a civil conflict.
The fact that we're on the edge of one tells us a lot about what foreign actors have been able to accomplish in our society.
When remote viewers see remote view sessions related to future internal conflicts in the U S that is absolutely information that also connects to the world war three scenario.
A hundred percent.
Um, Courtney's group has, has done a lot of work looking at, um, individuals who came across the border with other migrants.
They are not anti-migrant.
Um, and I'm not making a political statement either way.
Uh, what I'm saying is that they themselves don't have an ideology that is anti-migration.
Um, their concern was that a certain number of people who came in when the border was more porous were, uh, state sponsored foreign actors.
Uh, potentially armed and they have done some work about that.
And they believe that as a significant threat, they believe that should the, the war continue to escalate, we would see.
Uh, what ostensibly would be terror cells in the U S become operational.
That is not, um, leaking any kind of classified information.
That is something the U S government itself is openly concerned about.
Um, and you can see it on, you know, every once in a while on CNN or other, you know, television networks.
Um, so that, that's a big concern.
That's one of the reasons that they're trying to rush out the most violent, in my opinion, they're trying to rush out the most violent individuals.
The individuals that deemed most capable of violence, uh, because they may deem those as individuals most likely to be connected to these organizations.
Um, like some of them, you know, what is represented as a, a gang, the, the, that Venezuelan group, that's not a gang.
It's a paramilitary organization, right?
So a lot of it comes down to people trying to shape the narrative for their own ideological reasons, but unintentionally misleading everyone as they do that.
Um, so that's something that Courtney is, is concerned about.
Uh, they have done a number of sessions about what weapon, um, if, if Europe, if, um, Western European nations send soldiers into Ukraine, uh, and, or, uh,
or not, and their data says, if they don't send soldiers into Ukraine, then we're sort of in this open-ended situation.
We'll see what happens in the future.
If they do send soldiers into Ukraine, and this is the, you know what, if the fact that we need a remote viewer to tell us, this shows exactly where we are right now with our reasoning ability in a society.
Of course, if the English, the Germans, the French, if they send soldiers into Ukraine, of course, Russia is going to respond.
Russia has said they're going to respond.
Right.
However, the remote viewing data, as if, like, if we needed it in this case, clearly shows that the Russians would respond, uh, and attack Western Europe with weapons of mass destruction.
It also clearly indicates a weapon being used in the ocean.
And the future forecasting group, they also have put out, uh, session after session, video after video going back years related to the escalation of this conflict.
Uh, but the cognitive sense that they create by then trying to sell crypto the next week short circuits, anyone taking that information and using it to, to more accurately assess, uh, assess their own, you know, make their own decisions about how they should assess the data and what they do with it.
Right.
So the future forecasting, and I'm, and I'm just paraphrasing it here, right.
We put a couple of videos up there.
They're not going to come here and talk and, and, and break down the data for you and join us.
They're not friends of our space.
Uh, they have, um, they have seen a series of events, uh, most concerning, um, at one point, a couple of years ago, they, they saw, uh, a luminous series of luminosity events.
And the first luminosity event, like the first sign basically was a large blackout in which they perceived at that point to be in New York city.
Um, however, that blackout was supposed to happen in April.
So it was a bit concerning when we had a large blackout in April, it was not in New York city.
It was in Spain and Europe.
However, the timing, right.
And the imagery were sort of spot on.
Hopefully it's not that that wasn't the luminosity event because, uh, the next stage of that three stage process would be, uh, a July and August series of events involving an economic crash, military conflict, and a transfer of power in the West.
Um, the astrology, again, as we started this video or this presentation, right.
This recording, the astrology clearly indicates that that's likely to happen, um, in August.
So.
And between now and August, I hope more than anything that this is next year.
I got to be honest with you.
Like, I, I really hope that this is all a series of events.
I mean, I don't hope this events happen, but I would rather they happen next year than this year.
However, the astrology and the fact that they, um, the, uh, blackout happened in April.
That's very concerning.
So if that series of events were to begin or it's already begun, but if it were to happen in July and August, then the next point of concern would be, uh, September and October.
And the videos, I cannot find them anymore.
I don't know if they took them down.
God knows they have other videos about world war three.
Some of them are in the nest.
However, they did see impacts in the United States.
They saw impacts of different kinds, uh, explosive events, energetic events, I like to call them.
Uh, but what they saw that was particularly notable was they saw flood on the East coast, um, in September, October, and a large number of people, um, heading West, migrating West.
Uh, that is again, like this is, this is.
This comes up in data after data, after data, it comes up in prophetic data.
It comes up in remote viewing data.
It came up in Morgan's data, right?
About Putin using, um, a weapon in the ocean.
This is, um, the future forecasting group.
Also, they remote viewed a, a quote, quote unquote, profit from the 1930s and forties.
Alloys Erlenmeyer, who we'll talk about next time.
And, uh, he vividly describes, um, a world war three scenario.
That seems to be in accord with the remote viewing data that people get today.
And his scenario ended with a weapon being deployed for the Russians flying out and dropping something into the middle of the Atlantic ocean and causing a, uh, a large tsunami.
So that, that, that, that just keeps coming up over and over and over again.
Am I concerned like that it's this year?
I mean, the astrology, the astrology does suggest something like that could happen this year.
I think it definitely suggests something that can happen in the next few years.
That's why I'm like, I'm clutching on to, I hope it's next year.
Um, if, if we see the escalation, um, that we're concerned about over the next few months, then I will be very concerned about that event happening this fall.
Is it possible it could be next fall?
Yes.
But the more of these events fall into place, the more concerning it is.
Obviously, if an event like that were to happen, it's not just the damage that we've done to one area of our country.
Right.
If that type of event were to happen, that would, um, that would just destroy the global economy.
That would, that would send us back in time.
I would have such a significant effect.
It would send us back like the way we live would, would, you know, the EMP would be, the thing about EMPs is EMPs might be overhyped.
I'm not saying they are, but EMP weapons supposedly have been used in the Ukraine.
And then they just turn the power back on.
You can turn on everything.
It's just the amount of time it takes to get everything back on.
And the concept is if you used a big enough EMP, then society would collapse before anyone can get the power back on.
Those people know more than I do.
If they say it's a serious threat, then I believe it.
However, you know, if someone found a way to flood the East coast, that would be, that would be a pretty apocalyptic scenario for the entire world.
Um, just from that, that one event, that's a pretty significant doomsday weapon.
Now, it so happens that, uh, Josh Maitland, who is a friend of our space, I think he is.
Um, and he was the remote viewer that appeared with Dan Waits, uh, world astrology report in that Astro RV video.
Um, you know, that Morgan and I have talked about, uh, he saw, um, you know, uh, China and Taiwan.
He saw, uh, Russia and Ukraine.
He had information because the task was so broad.
They got, oh, he got all kinds of, he got 17 hours of information, right?
He saw, um, I think, I think that's what he said, 17 hours.
He saw, um, Israel and Iran, which we've talked about, like, as a necessary precursor to, um, or the step on the escalatory ladder, right?
And, uh, he saw Doomer's guy, Chris Bledsoe, popped into his session.
So, I don't know how active he is on UFO Twitter.
I don't think he's active on UFOX at all, uh, Josh Maitland.
Uh, UFOs are a preoccupation of Dan's, and that, that is something we're going to talk about in a UFO episode, uh, which I have promised to hold, uh, should Doomer Daddy ever, um, want to spend five or six hours hashing out the details of, of the UFO.
Um, I'm, I have committed to doing that.
It's not my, um, first love, but it is something that we could talk about.
Um, he did see Chris Bledsoe, sort of an AOL, and, uh, he did see, uh, nuclear weapons being used in conjunction with the appearance of UFOs.
Now, I think that it is all but certain that should we actually get to the point where major nations are shooting missiles at each other, that UFOs will be present.
The question that I would have is, uh, whose UFOs those would be, right?
I, I don't know anything about what, I don't know anything more than anyone else here knows about what the U.S. may or may not have.
I think it's significant that the modern UFO, like the very modern, like the, the, the wave of UFO disclosure that we're talking about right now, in my opinion, and I'm not part of the community, so I'm sure I'll get corrected on this.
But what I saw was this, um, emergence of a disclosure movement around the time, uh, Russia invaded Ukraine.
And, uh, and the U.S. was having problems with China and COVID.
And what I saw, what I interpreted, was information being released by the United States Navy related to interactions with these craft, and the way I interpreted that was a form of saber rattling.
I interpreted that as a form of disclosure of our own capabilities to our adversaries.
Saying like, oh, well, you know, these things are out there.
We don't know who does them, but I'll tell you something.
These things are so far beyond us.
Uh, they would be so far beyond you too.
You don't even want to imagine what they're going to do to you.
And it seemed that the release, the military release of information related to UFOs, and the recent series of military and intelligence related UFO whistleblowers, uh, occurred following the initiation of this conflict between the United States, China, and Russia.
And so I look at all of them as being a part of us communicating, you know, like the, the purple frog in the, in the rainforest, like, uh, you know, other countries sort of boast about their capabilities because that's how they deter everyone.
We don't do that because our capabilities are so advanced, I believe.
Um, however, as, as a conflict was beginning, I think that we wanted to shake, you know, rattle our sabers.
And let them know that we have very advanced stuff.
And so I think that's what was going on there with that Navy disclosure and with this series of whistleblowers.
That's my opinion, uh, that we're attempting to, um, to frighten our adversaries.
Uh, however, he did see, like Josh Maitland did see UFOs and, and nuclear weapons interacting.
I believe that what I said before, I'll say it for a third time, uh, any type of countermeasure to nuclear weapons is so highly classified that none of us is ever going to know, nor should we really speculate.
I think that as to what exactly they are.
I think that if we were though, talking about like the common understanding that UFOs may interfere with nuclear weapons, we can't assume that they're actually non-human intelligences.
We could assume that they are nation states sending the message to other nation states that they can shut down their, their weapons.
Ashton, um, Ashton, you know, the guy with the, the guy with the airplane, right?
When I said, well, why is the government letting this guy talk about the airplane and the three orbs teleporting the airplane?
If this is super, super secret technology, if the U S has teleportation technology, then why is Ashton able to mouth off about it?
And why is he like able to do these videos where he's like, I'm going to change the world.
I'm not going to let them hide this technology anymore.
And like, you know, I mean, if this was really the technology, the secret that they said it was, they would, you know, he wouldn't be talking like he wouldn't be allowed to talk even, you know, we know in the past, right?
If you're going to leak national security information, at some point, they're going to stop you.
No one has even attempted to stop him, right?
No one doesn't want Ashton talking about what he's talking about.
That's a fact.
Okay.
They would have taken him down.
He would have at least taken him down electronically.
His videos would disappear, et cetera.
They definitely like if he was putting that, you know, his life would be in danger.
And it's not.
So why, why would they want that knowledge?
Well, Ashton himself has drawn the conclusion and continues to talk his, his, his message has changed from we have this, this technology and I'm going to force disclosure to.
So, and if you look at his, his posts, you'll see that this is the case.
His posts now main, mainly hinge on the Russians and Chinese can't threaten us because we have teleportation technology.
Therefore, nuclear weapons are obsolete.
Now the flaw in his reasoning, well, let's just say he's a, he's a good faith actor.
And this is all organic, right?
Coming from him and not part of some message that we're sending to, to foreign countries.
The flaw in that is, is scalability.
I mean, not only are these weapons designed by countries to be able to evade countermeasures, but they're designed to be fired in mass.
They're not designed, right?
So each missile, and some of the people here know, like some of the people here have military knowledge and other people don't know anything about this, right?
These missiles, they carry multiple warheads.
And so when the missile, you know, punches up into the sky, right?
When it gets to the arc and its trajectory, it breaks up and essentially becomes a bunch of smaller missiles.
At that point, you call them warheads, but it's basically what it is.
A bunch of, of projectiles fly off in different directions.
Some of them are, are filled with confetti and shit.
Like some of them are just designed to evade or destroy countermeasures.
And some of them are real, you know, warheads.
So if you're talking about launching 500 missiles or a thousand missiles, you're talking about conservatively 2,000 warheads.
And you're talking about it happening in 20 minutes, 30 minutes, right?
Depending on where, you know, if it was launched from submarines, you're talking about it like happening in 10 or 20 minutes.
So the fact that we have teleportation is a lot different from saying we can use teleportation on 2,000 warheads at the same time within 20 minutes.
And they're moving too, right?
And the fact that we took down, hypothetically, based on what this guy says, because I'm not making that argument.
I'm saying, he says the fact that we took out down this, this jet plane, it definitely should not indicate to him or anyone else that we're capable of averting World War III and the use of weapons of mass destruction.
That is not a valid line of reasoning.
And the fact he's making it while he claims to be so intelligent and have such knowledge is highly questionable.
Combined with the fact that he's, you know, not under any pressure to stop talking about what is supposedly, according to him, the most classified thing on Earth.
It's not, but according to him, it is, right?
The other whistleblowers who emerge at the same time, right?
They're sort of being unveiled or revealed to be clowns.
I don't follow, again, UFOlogy is not my first love, but, you know, I know that, right?
I know that there's a guy, Lou Elizondo, who his job was to harass people, harass other whistleblowers, right?
He was counterintelligence.
And now he's a whistleblower and he got into everyone's good graces.
And now he's showing up at, like, apparently government hearings and showing pictures of crop circles and claiming they're the UFOs.
And making the whole thing kind of ridiculous.
And that would tend to show that he's not a serious whistleblower.
And it would tend to show that his message wasn't serious at all.
So where, right?
I think he's associated with the Navy, but I'm not positive.
So, like, why did they all come forward at the same time?
Well, I mean, reason would tell us it was to reveal our capabilities, not to talk about non-human intelligence.
And to reveal a limited set of capabilities that intimidated foreign governments.
Which, you know, I think they can reason to.
And I think they could reason that if we have teleportation or if we have, you know, UFO-like craft, that doesn't equal complete, to completely shutting down their weapon systems.
Just the same way that if a UFO shuts down an ICBM in Germany, or something, I don't know, it wasn't in Germany.
You know, if a UFO went to a Russian ICBM and a US ICBM and shut them down, you know, then we say, okay, non-human intelligence is telling us they can shut down our weapons.
And then people are being abducted, and these non-human intelligence, supposedly non-human intelligence, are telling them, we're not going to let you have a nuclear war.
That's not, it's not, you know, reason does not support that.
Reason does not support that capability, because as we've talked about recently with the abduction phenomenon, you have to get into the numbers and the logistics.
Right, reason is about looking at the logistics.
It's not about looking at the story that we're being told.
So you've got to get into what would it take to do that.
And when you go down that path, and you start thinking about all the coordination, right, could one, if you had teleportation, could you take out an airplane?
Sure.
And if you could take out an airplane, is it possible to take out a missile?
Can you take out 2,000?
Well, do you have 2,000 teleporters?
Do you have 2,000 teams?
How many satellites do you have?
You know, how much, what type of intelligence do you have?
Like, is it possible that an alien group could do it?
Sure.
It's possible that a galaxy-spanning empire could take out all of America's and Russia's ICBMs in mid-flight.
Yeah, okay.
They would have to forward deploy quite a number of resources.
But let's say the moon is hollow, and the moon is full of, you know, little rooms with air traffic controllers operating technology, you know, UFOs and teleportation technology.
And they're all scanning all the time, the Earth.
And, yeah, I mean, it's hypothetically possible.
But the further you go down that line of thinking, the less reasonable it is, right?
And whatever is, yeah, it's just not something that you can take seriously, ultimately.
So you can say, like, will non-human intelligence stop us from having a nuclear war?
Well, I think it's ridiculous.
However, let's look at what the data says.
Because we've talked about the fact, like, we're never going to know, nor should we know, what countermeasures we have to the use of weapons of mass destruction by foreign actors, foreign countries.
So, but they have a sort of an idea, right?
And so their goal, and as ours, is to design weapons that other nations can't stop.
And so the Russians came up with this idea of using these underwater nuclear weapons.
So the question isn't, can non-human intelligence hypothetically stop ICBMs?
Yeah, possibly.
And I don't know if they would have a motive to do that.
When we're talking about them causing a pole shift in order to wipe out, you know, wipe out humanity and start over again, one day and the next day saying they're going to stop us from using nuclear weapons, it just doesn't really add up, right?
It doesn't add up that they would save us from nuclear disasters so they could wipe us out with a pole shift.
However, if we accept all that is true, then we get to the point that a weapon has been designed, at least one that we know of has been designed, that people are talking about, that could evade all of that.
So the question comes down to, you know, then it's not, can the non-human intelligence stop ICBMs?
And when we look at the information that Josh Maitland got, his information ended with an attack using tsunamis.
So that's the information he got, right?
That's the information Morgan got, Putin using a weapon in the ocean.
The Russians have made statements they're going to do it.
The remote viewers are seeing it.
Josh Maitland saw it.
Future Forecasting Group has seen something like that, although I don't think they phrase it in that sense.
Courtney, Barsight Prime, their information also talks about, right?
Rock Archie, that's posted in the nest.
He clearly saw a weapon being used in the ocean.
So I don't know if all these people are familiar with the Poseidon.
I don't think that it's an attempt to manufacture an idea that this thing will be used.
I think this is genuine information.
Chris Bledsoe.
Chris Bledsoe comes up in the World Astrology Report video.
And Josh Maitland saw Chris Bledsoe.
So let's look at a couple of things about Chris Bledsoe, right?
Chris says he saw the lady and he saw, and I'm not super familiar with it because I'm not, UFO is not my passion.
I just know like what I've heard from other people in UFO X, right?
So Chris Bledsoe saw this lady, this non-human, supposedly non-human intelligence, which had a profound effect on him.
This non-human intelligence told him that a series of events were going to occur.
As usual, right, we know these events, these interactions tend to be deceptive.
Even when people have strong religious feelings about them.
In the case of her prophecy to him, it has something to do with Easter next year, which is an interesting point I'm going to circle back to.
But it also had to do with when Regulus rises in the heart of the Sphinx or over the Sphinx, something like that, during Easter.
And we know that that is astronomically impossible.
So right there, she added something astronomically impossible, unless the planet goes through a shift, right?
Like if, if we shift, then I don't even know if it's possible then, but I guess it could be possible.
Like if the planet shifted in some way, perhaps it would be possible if we were the new South Hemisphere.
Don't quote me on that because I don't know for certain, but hypothetically, maybe it would be possible.
We're not going to have a nuclear war following, as Doomer touched on.
Yeah.
By the way, I'm going to start a drinking game.
Everybody, anytime you hear JT say he's not part of the UFO community, we're not part of the UFO X, drink and prepare to die.
But on a serious note, and you might already know this, but he said in one of the Bledsoe accounts of this prophecy, that it's when Regulus, I think, rises in Leo, because the Sphinx used to be a lion.
I don't know if that makes a difference, but since you're an astrologer, I felt I should add that.
I don't know if that's possible.
I have to look into it.
It's a fixed star, so I don't think it can rise in Leo.
However, I will look into it, and I will have that information for our next space related to this subject on Thursday.
We'll have a space on Monday where we're going to read a love letter written to us by a Reddit monitor, but our next space after that will be Thursday, and I'll have that information at that time.
What's notable about...
That's awesome, man.
Yeah.
Okay, so what's notable about Chris Bledsoe is, right?
What's the other part of that?
An attack through the ocean.
That's part of his information.
So we both fixate, and I know Fringe has mentioned this, and with good cause, that he said the UFOs were going to appear when Israel and Iran start shooting at each other.
So Israel and Iran are shooting at each other.
Where are the UFOs, right?
I guess he said that relates to New Jersey and the drones.
I don't know.
You can't follow these people because they're being deceived, and then they're trying...
The cognitive dissonance sets in, and they're trying to fit everything together, so the story's going to change to try to make it make sense.
However, from what I understand, ultimately, the lady did say that there would be a flooding event as the result of some kind of attack.
So even the apparition, the divine feminine apparition that everyone is so worked up about, even she apparently predicts this attack.
I will point this out, and this is another piece of personal information.
I did disclose in our last video that I went through a period when Neptune was conjunct my Ascendant, where I had some pretty serious stuff happen.
And, you know, it's a deceptive influence.
You have these, like, idealized moments, and you have this, like, enlightenment experience, but you also have this deception and mental breakdown, which I kind of had a mental breakdown.
During that period, and I forgot to mention this the other day, I did also, in prayer, I spent a few months in prayer asking about the possibility of nuclear war, because it's something I was concerned about at that time, in 2000, when everyone else said it was crazy.
And, you know, when it would happen.
Now, I don't hear voices.
I've heard voices twice in my life.
It's actually not unusual.
Most people will hear a voice once or twice in their life, not like this.
But the other time, I can't remember what it said, so it wasn't notable.
I think I just kept moving, and perhaps it was my neighbor yelling about something.
However, this was when I was in Salt Lake, and all this weird stuff was going on, and this was definitely not me hearing a neighbor and misspeaking it.
I did hear a voice.
It was just very quickly, you know.
You can say it was crazy.
You say I was having mental problems, but I don't have those problems now.
And I wasn't, I wasn't, I was never diagnosed with a mental problem of any kind, except for anxiety.
So I did hear a voice.
I was on, I think I was on the bus or something, and I had been praying, like, really hard for two or three months on this subject.
And I was thinking about it in my head, and I asked again, and I was praying in my head, and I asked again.
And I heard a voice, and it said, and again, these, we know this phenomenon is deceptive.
We know it is.
The voice said April 1st.
Okay.
I've thought about that a lot.
That's all I said, April 1st.
I've thought about that a lot over the years, and if there's any reason to that.
And what I can tell you is, having thought about it, I think that the best possible, not the best possible day, it's a horrible thing.
If you were going to attack the United States, I think April 1st would be a good, there's a good case to be made that April 1st would be the day.
Simply because a certain percentage of people, first of all, it would happen around four o'clock in the morning, right?
So most people wouldn't be up.
But the people who were up manning infrastructure or whatever, if you were going to pick one specific day, that people would be less likely to do whatever they had to do to shut off the water or shut down the nuclear power plants or whatever had to be done at that point.
It would be on April 1st, right?
It was less likely to flee, less likely to take cover, more likely to walk out in the middle of a nuclear explosion because I think it's all a joke.
Um, so I have thought about that, uh, from a religious, and fuck, okay.
I don't, I don't want to get sucked into X nonsense.
Um, there are religious calendars that historically have been associated with certain events.
Uh, one of those events involves, and I'm, I'm avoiding because I don't want to get sucked into the, the, the hate and craziness on X.
One of those calendars involves, uh, a period of time where people are supposed to take shelter and, um, from, you know, a passing cloud that at one point in time wiped out the first born children of Egypt.
Um, the original concept of those, those calendars, the prophetic calendars, wasn't that it was a day that you remembered something bad happening on.
It was that there were days when bad things happened, right?
So there are days when your, your tribe or your religion would be threatened.
There'd be days when you would celebrate victories over others.
And throughout history, throughout a period of thousands of years, not every year, but repeatedly, you would have events happen on those days.
So I have always thought that the specifically to me, I have always been most concerned about the years when April 1st happens to be a day like that on one of those religious calendars.
And I can tell you that that is the case on, in 2026, I'm not making predictions.
I'm just saying that 2026 has always been on my radar for that reason.
Uh, Easter is tied in with this other holiday.
And I believe seven days later, uh, or maybe 14 days later, whatever it is, because they, it's supposed to be tied together, but they always screwed up.
Um, that is notable that they should talk about, you know, stars falling from the sky related to Easter.
When I would be more concerned about stars falling from sky related to another day that is tied into Easter.
Um, but I wouldn't, I wouldn't be ascribing any intention or participation on the behalf of anyone who follows that religion in the events.
I would be talking about it as an, as an actual prophetic calendar.
Um, so that's, that's all I have to say.
I know I'm talking around the bush with that, but I just don't want to get sucked into the crazy hatred that's taking over the world right now.
Um, so that's where I say, like, even though the association is, you know,
astrology and the news, I tend to predict that these problems are going to happen this year.
I'm like, well, maybe, maybe it will happen next year.
So when I hear Chris, Chris Blitzo and with the regulus thing, and I don't know if that's, if we can, if we can make that into a real thing.
But when I hear about the Easter next year, then I'm kind of like, well, that does fit in with other possibilities.
That does fit in with other predictions that people have made in the past, historically prophecies, et cetera.
So perhaps, you know, that's when my mind wants to like the wishful thing that happens in my mind.
And I'm like, I want to believe it's next year.
I want to believe it's, if it's going to happen, it's going to happen after next spring.
Eloise Erlemeyer, Erlemeyer, who the future forecasting group looked into, they, they remote viewed a profit.
Um, you know, he always said it would be in the fall or the spring because, uh, in his visions, you know, there was still snow in the mountains and that only happened in fall and in spring.
Um, so I think that we're either looking at something that would happen like this fall.
I know that, right, when you talk about pole shift and shit, right, like Birdie, Birdie Jarowski, Jarkowski, I don't know, Prudence Calabrese.
She goes by Birdie now, but she was on the Doom Room.
She was in the Doom Room.
One second, Morgan, I'm almost done with my rant.
She was in the Doom Room and she said, you know, it could be this fall.
She thinks it's going to happen in autumn because she saw leaves on the ground and she said it could happen this fall.
I mean, we can hope, knock on wood, that it would be a later fall, 2026 or later.
The information from many of the sessions related to natural disasters from future forecasting group, the dates that they tend to ascribe it in my experience and based on my imperfect memory, uh, would be late in 2026 or beyond.
So there is some hope that we may have a reprieve, but I really think we need to take it seriously.
This is something that could possibly happen, um, this fall and, and make our judgments based on, on following the news and the escalatory ladder that we've outlined here.
Go ahead, Morgan.
Yeah, no, no, no, no worries.
Um, that's great.
I just wanted to, uh, point out the time.
Uh, we've got our friend, uh, Joseph is here.
Um, and I think he, so he's going to be running a space, uh, almost just right about now.
So as soon as we get, uh, things wrapped up, I want to encourage everyone, um, if they're interested to, uh, to go over and join his space.
Um, Joseph, uh, you're on the mic.
Have you got, uh, have you got any comments or, or anything to say on that?
Yeah.
Uh, I'm going to delay it.
You know what I mean?
Like I had my own things I wanted to say based on your space.
Um, but I mean, if you guys are willing to join me, then it'd be kind of ridiculous just to do it on my own.
So, um, I'm just going to stick around here.
Uh, I'll delay that or cancel it.
I mean, who cares?
It's just a space.
I can do it another time.
So, but I'm going to, I think I'm going to stick around here for, for now.
Well, cause what we were thinking of doing is trying to wrap up all comments and head over at seven.
So if you wanted to delay it till seven, um, and then just do that transition, if that, if that, or if you think it's better to do another day, it's up to you.
But we were going to, you know, encourage everyone to head over at seven and join the space.
Uh, we just want to leave some time for people to ask questions.
If people have comments, questions, whatever, criticisms.
Oh, for sure.
Yeah, that'd be cool.
Maybe we'll do that.
I'll have like a, an after space for you guys.
All right, cool.
So we just, the thing with that is if you cancel the one you have, we won't have a link.
So we just need you to reschedule so we can put the link up in the nest so everyone can head over.
Right.
Okay.
I'll do that.
Cool.
All right.
Was that, um, is that what you had Morgan or do you have other, uh, something else at this time?
Uh, no, I just wanted to, uh, double check with Joseph on that and just.
You know, make sure we weren't, uh, cutting into each other's, uh, things.
Yeah.
And, uh, I really appreciate that Morgan.
That's pretty cool.
Um, yeah.
Yeah, no, you say good things about us and anyone who says good things about us, we got to, you know, we're all in this together, right?
It's not an ego thing.
It's not a narcissism thing.
It's like, we're, we're trying to get information out.
If you're trying to get it out, if we're talking about the same thing, then, you know, we should be, we should be working together.
We should be helping each other out.
And, uh, God knows like we don't get nearly the type of numbers that doom room does, but doomer and fringe have helped us immensely.
Right.
By giving us the opportunity.
So we can only pay it forward in what little way that we're capable of doing.
Um, there was something that I, I should have mentioned earlier, but I didn't.
And I might've got dumped if I had mentioned it.
Um, but it's definitely something for today and not for Thursdays, uh, thinking about the end of the world.
Um, and so if I get dumped, uh, then we'll just start talking about it.
Right.
It's just going to be quick.
And that is when you're assessing the, um, the, the danger of escalation in this scenario, when you're assessing, like, how far are we along on that curve?
Uh, the, the arc of global conflict, there is something that a lot of people don't understand.
It is public knowledge.
It is not classified knowledge.
Uh, but it's something that people don't understand about the way the military works in our day and age, not only our military, but other militaries as well.
All right.
And that is when you are in uniform as a soldier, you represent the government you represent, right?
If you are in an American uniform, a Russian uniform, a North Korean uniform, a Venezuelan uniform, then the way that you act and behave when you're in that uniform reflects directly on your country.
Hey, a U S soldier could inadvertently start a global conflict just by doing something really stupid and a Russian soldier, vice versa.
Now, generally when those things happen, the countries diffuse the situation, right?
They understand, you know, this was a one-off, this was a fluke, this was a mistake.
However, the weight of that uniform is significant.
It makes you a representative.
If you are not wearing that uniform, you are not officially a representative.
And in our modern age, right, we've developed a lot of forms of plausible deniability when it comes to fighting.
Between ourselves and other countries, other countries and each other, like, this is on the global stage.
Like, how can we fight each other and attack each other without technically fighting and attacking each other?
Like, how can we do it in a indirect way?
Right?
And of course, that's nonsense.
But because of how we think about war and because we're trying to avoid conflict, right?
We have to invent special categories of attacking, limited forms of attack, police actions, interventions.
We have to be able to bomb Iran and then say, hey, we destroyed their nuclear facilities.
And they say, no, you didn't.
Well, we've got to be able to do that.
No matter what people call them, people can say whatever they want.
They can criticize, okay, but that's part of avoiding escalation, regardless of how you feel politically.
And they have to be able to land a couple of cruise missiles on an airfield and say, wait, we destroyed their mighty base, even if they didn't.
Right?
Because it's that posturing that allows us to act without fully committing to an act.
It sucks because war sucks and human nature sucks.
But it doesn't necessarily mean it's stupid or evil when it happens.
Like, sometimes these things can happen and it can be to avoid conflict, to avoid escalation.
Now, in some cases, particularly the cases of World War III, it's unlikely that we're going to be allowed to avoid escalation forever.
And that's where non-human intelligence may come in, right?
We don't have information about that.
It does seem that, it does seem like, based on our data, that the causing of distress in other people's data is part of the program.
And so when you look at, for instance, the pole shift, from that perspective, based on the data that we use, the mass distress that would occur would be part of the harvest, which is a term that comes up in a lot of people's data.
If they're harvesting distress through a pole shift, you could sure as hell imagine they would harvest distress and suffering from the events leading up to a pole shift, including war.
And the results of war, right?
So it may be that non-human intelligence is the reason why we can't avoid this horrible Catch-22 situation we keep finding ourselves in that is leading us to military conflict.
So hopefully not, knock on wood.
I mean, I would love if divine intervention would stop all of this.
I really wouldn't.
I don't, I'm not making a political statement.
I don't think that Trump is divine intervention.
I know that people differ in that.
I don't have a political opinion, really, but I don't, that's not how I see the world.
I just would hope for some sort of divine intervention.
But I, based on what I believe about reality, I don't see that as a possibility.
But I hope other people are right and I'm wrong.
I don't.
Because these are terrible things.
And it's going to be terrible to live through for whatever period that you live through it, if it happens.
We have to understand that when we talk about, like, how far along are we?
We say, well, this is like, the people in the news, what if we have a new Cold War with Russia and China?
I'm like, dude, man, we are so far beyond that point.
We are so far beyond that point right now, right?
Because when they talk about Western mercenaries, okay, you have this idea, right, because of this plausible deniability scenario.
When we talk about Eastern Russian mercenaries, when we talk about Yergi Purgosin and his mercenary group,
or we talk about Western mercenaries, we have this idea that they are groups of adventurous individuals who operate independently
and not in accord with their nations of origin.
And that is, it's fucking ridiculous.
It's like the concept of non-state-sponsored terrorism.
I know that you've been, people have been indoctrinated into believing that.
There's no such thing as non-state-sponsored terrorism.
It's what state sponsors it is the issue.
But even the most primitive states don't generally allow foreign forces to set up armed camps in the middle of them,
training for violent action, unless they sponsor that behavior in some way.
Generally speaking, that's the core concept behind statehood, is that you stop random groups of brigands and pirates
from setting up camps and raising armies on your territory, right?
So when they say, like, well, this group is, you know, they were training in Iraq, but no, they weren't state-sponsored.
They were training in Iran, but they weren't state-sponsored.
Or even they were training in Afghanistan, but they weren't state-sponsored.
It's fucking ridiculous.
In the same way, mercenary armies, numbering in the tens of thousands, don't recruit from, train in,
in areas and draw from, right, the military and the populace of a country that they're not part of,
they're not connected to.
So there's really no such thing as an independent mercenary fighting force.
It's a force with plausible deniability.
And there's a term for this, and I might get the dump button.
The term is called sheep dipping.
And sheep dipping is when you take an active member of a military
and you take off their uniform and you put them in mercenary clothes,
you send them overseas to fight, you discharge them, and you send them to fight.
You have plausible deniability.
And then when they get done with that fight, you put them back in the uniform
and you give them their back pay and you give them their pension.
Technically, according to the way that we look at war in the modern age,
that is not war.
Technically, it's mercenaries.
However, if those mercenary organizations are fighting, right,
the mercenary organizations of other countries,
if Yergi Purgosin, late Yergi Purgosin, so we've been told, right,
if that crazy screwball with the coke and the hand grenade and the plane,
supposedly, right, what a crazy story.
If his organization is in East Africa fighting against,
I don't even know what Blackwater became.
Like, there's another name for it now, right?
Like, that's not adventurers.
That's not Dungeons and Dragons, right?
Those people are, a lot of those people who are fighting,
they're members of the militaries of the countries of their origin
who are temporarily not official and in foreign, you know,
or in other uniforms.
The same is true in Ukraine.
So if you say we are not fighting,
Western forces and Eastern forces are not fighting,
it's not true.
It's true semantically.
It's a loophole.
But they are very real, right?
In a very real sense, we are in an armed conflict already.
So the reason that's important is that when you judge where you are in the escalatory ladder,
you're going to say, well, we haven't even started shooting at each other yet.
False, right?
I mean, they tell you that, what do they tell you?
We're sending advanced weapon systems in to people who don't speak our language
and have no access to those type of weapon systems
and we're training them up in about 10 days
and then we're sending them off to fight and they're using them?
That's fucking asinine.
Of course not.
Okay?
They're being run by mercenaries.
Those mercenaries are, you know, a year ago, they weren't mercenaries.
And in two years, they won't be mercenaries anymore.
It's all an attempt to diffuse escalation.
And in that sense, it's good, right?
I mean, it sounds ridiculous or horrible,
but it's the reason that we haven't had a general exchange with the Russians for 30 or 40 years, right?
So it worked in the Cold War.
It's working now so far.
It's keeping us all from, you know, having bombs land on our heads so far.
So it's not ridiculous.
And it's really not as awful as it sounds
because you have to always factor in the alternative
that you don't want to necessarily imagine or believe would happen.
But you do have to believe it because the people who make these decisions
know those things happen or will happen, right?
So, yes, we are very far along the escalatory ladder.
And we are far enough along the escalatory ladder, in my personal opinion,
based on my outsider information and the astrology and the remote viewing,
that I am personally concerned that this is something that could happen this year.
I am not convinced that this is something that will happen this year.
I don't think anyone should be convinced of any date or any prediction.
I don't think anyone should be convinced of the reality of any prediction.
Absolutely.
I don't think anyone should ever be convinced of the reality or accuracy of anything told to a human being
by a supposed non-human intelligence of any kind.
Whether it's a tall white person or a short reptilian person or a bug-eyed gray or a little purple man.
I don't, you know, if you wake up in the middle of the night and there's some weirdo in your room
and he's whispering to you about, you know, the environment and nuclear war and messages for your people
and your messianic mission, like, right there, you've got to discount absolutely everything that was said, in my opinion.
I know that people who have that experience don't.
I think they've been affected in some way.
They've been manipulated in some way.
Yeah, I think a normal human being's response would be, if a weirdo is in my room in the middle of the night,
like Donnie Darko, right, then, you know, I've got to discount all this right from the jump.
So there's something that's being done to them in those scenarios that short-circuit that normal human reaction
and cause them to take these things seriously and then move forward.
And some of it is virtue signaling, right?
Some of it is that all of a sudden it's very special.
We've talked about that.
Like, you really have to watch out for the effect it has on human psychology to believe that you're special.
You're in some sort of messianic mission.
You've got to save the world.
So even if Donnie Darko shows up in your room in the middle of the night,
if he tells you that you're going to save the world,
then you might go out and spread that information unthinkingly to other people.
The same thing could be true.
You know, I'm not, I don't know, man.
Could the lady be real?
Yeah, I'm not, I'm not down with the divine feminine thing,
but people have remote viewed that encounter and the data they get is that he spoke to something.
Much like Courtney Brown is speaking to someone during his,
during his UFO meetings where they're sitting there with the sunglasses staring at the ceiling.
The data seems to indicate they're talking to something.
It doesn't mean it's not deceptive, right?
Messengers of deception.
This is something that long-term UFO investigators from back in my time, right?
When I was associated with MoveOn, right?
This is something that back then they had figured out,
which is that this is a deceptive phenomenon and you cannot trust anything that they say.
Doomer and I had this discussion the other night where I challenged,
and this is something we disagree on, right?
I challenge the fact that there are subjects they don't want us to talk about that people are talking about.
I think that they, they want that information out.
If, oh, William is requesting, let me see if I can get him here.
If, if, if, if, if you are, um, if you are, uh, remember, you have this, like, torturous experience.
This is a tough experience and you can't remember anything else, but, oh, but you can't remember these three details.
Um, and you get this terrible feeling like, oh, they don't want me to talk about this.
I'm in danger, right?
But then you're not in danger, you know, if 200 people around the Kennedy assassination can disappear, you know,
and that's, that's hardly a unique circumstance.
And this is probably the country where that happens least, a major country, right?
If people can just have these, not disappear, but have these untimely ends,
then if they didn't really want you, then if these, these almost omnipotent aliens didn't want you talking about,
I don't know, some piece of information, I mean, dude, you just disappear.
People disappear, right?
And there's no power on earth, according to our own government and, and people who believe in, in the alien abduction phenomenon.
Like there's no power on earth that can stop them.
So there's no way that you could possibly stop them from disappearing.
It is highly suspect because this is how information is disseminated here with human beings.
So we only have that as a model.
So we have to imagine that they have similar techniques and strategies that we have because we really can't imagine anything else.
So we have to assume they have limited hangouts.
We have to assume that they would sometimes create conflicts and discussions and reveal information with the intention of creating conflicts and discussions.
And sometimes they would use reverse psychology and make it seem like they didn't want that information to be revealed.
But if we did that, that would be because we really wanted the information revealed, right?
Like if, if someone is a, quote, whistleblower and like, oh, the government's really angry at them and, oh, they've got these, you know, these threatening situations, but nothing happens to them, right?
Then, then the government isn't trying to stop them from releasing the information.
They're trying to make sure they release the information.
If something was going to happen to them, what would happen to them, right?
And that's, that's, that's a government.
That's not a galactic federation of planets, right?
Mr. Spock could just beam you up and, and, and you wouldn't say word one about any more of this information.
Part of the deception is creating the different lines of thinking and stopping people from talking about, I think what's most notable in this, just like on earth, what you look for in that situation is what is, what are the topics that very few people are talking about?
What are the topics that, that, you know, what are the topics that get the most pushback from the average person as opposed to what are the topics that seem to be creating competing narratives that draw investment from the public?
If there's a competing, if there's a narrative that draws investment from the public, it's probably not a secret, right?
Or something that people don't want you to know.
If, if there's something that everyone involved doesn't seem to be talking about, then that's where you want to look.
In my opinion, that's all my opinion.
And that's based on a subject, which I personally, you know, have a lot of distance between me and, and that subject.
I'm not going to say the words because I don't want to make everyone die from drinking.
Whenever I say, Doomer said that I say, it's true.
It's true.
Okay.
So this is everything I have, because we're going to do a part two on Thursday, thinking about the end of the world.
Or talking about the end of the world.
I haven't written up the, the deal yet.
And we're going to talk less about this information.
I, again, this is publicly accessed information, but it's also information where like, I get the whole thing, like disclosure and transparency.
Like, I understand that, you know, but we, we were, we rely on our government for safety.
Even if we don't approve of some of the things our governments do, we rely on them for safety and security.
We really do.
In the United States, we absolutely do.
We have enemies.
We may not want to believe we have enemies, but we do have enemies.
We have enemies around the world.
People suck.
And our nature is, it's horrible.
And we have enemies around the world.
We have people who like to, you know, cheered during 9-11, right?
We have people who want to see us harmed.
We'd like to see us disappear.
And some of those enemies have weapons and powerful weapons.
And so, you know, as whether our government is ideal or not is beside the point.
We do have to, we do have to understand that, that we rely on that, that government for protection.
So if there are things that we're not supposed to talk about, classified things, whatever, I don't believe people should be taking that information.
I'm not pro whistleblower with classified information.
I never have been.
I get disclosure.
I get the ethos of transparency, but I have a mother and a father and siblings and cats, right?
I have cats.
I have all kinds of people and also, you know, animals and a lot of people that I love.
And I want those people to be safe.
And that safety involves some information not being disclosed at this time, in my opinion.
So that's where I come from with that.
And I never want to cross that line.
And if I do cross that line by mistake, then I hope that they'll edit it out.
I do.
Okay.
So questions, comments, concerns?
Morgan, can you help me out here?
Can you talk about something?
Something?
Oh, God.
Anything.
How's the weather up there in Ontario?
Because we just told Joseph to hold off until seven o'clock and to schedule it then.
It's like 623.
You know, can I talk for another 37 minutes?
Just rambling on?
Yes.
But should I?
That's the question.
Well, I mean, we could do it in my next space or this one.
But, I mean, it is a direct follow-up to what you're just saying.
Because I know there's, you know, people frame it as from our knowledge base of the two different aspects.
And those two different aspects are the local geopolitical aspects, where you have, you know, America, U.S. supply chain.
And all those complicated aspects of that kind of war happening.
And then the current one happening now.
And then you have what the aliens are up to, what people or entities associated with those aliens are up to, like the lady and, you know, channelers, like a million channelers.
But there's a lot more elements than that, right?
Like, we have multiple dimensions.
They are, you know, manifesting in the physical.
But there's a lot of other stuff happening as well.
And there's a lot of other stuff happening underground as well from a lot of factions.
Like, it's insane if you take all of these entities, how many factions and groups.
And, I mean, it's so complicated.
And then you have not only those deep underground, but under them.
And some people, like, are probably still scoffing.
But, I mean, as far as I'm concerned at this point, I would have scoffed at this two years ago.
But inner earth is completely obvious to me now.
And, you know, you can make the argument that that's actually where the aliens are coming from instead of another dimension.
But that's a side point.
Like, how do we factor all of these in?
Because when you have governments like it that we have in the first geopolitical scenario, like, they're not just, you know, the Republicans and Democrats doing.
Like, they're interconnected and controlled, and there's violent control in factions and groups competing for all of these things that are made.
And the actual thing they're pushing forward is, at least as far as I'm concerned, you can call me crazy, I suppose.
I'm a little loopy these days.
But, I mean, that has to factor in more than what's going on on the ground, or at least as much.
What do you think about all of that, as far as, I suppose you're going to come at it from remote viewing data.
It'd be psyched if there is some.
Yeah, there's a couple of things.
One, Joseph, I got to tell you that you had paid me a tremendous compliment in one of your posts by saying that I was a great remote viewer.
But I'm not a remote viewer, I'm going to search her.
Morgan is the remote viewer, and Morgan and Deanne.
And I didn't want to, like, say that in your post, because I was really, like, it was a tremendous, tremendous compliment.
Like, they have an amazing ability, and, like, to have someone say that was really cool.
But I do happen to have spent a lot of time in my life researching a lot of esoteric material, and a lot of that esoteric material was related to previous clairvoyant movements.
So I have a better idea than most, and I don't want to toot my own horn, but it is possible that some of these subjects I have a better knowledge than other people do, including where it comes to what modern remote viewing data says about past remote viewing data.
I don't think anyone else has that knowledge to a greater degree than I do.
And so that's where I'm able to read things about remote viewing, but I myself am not a viewer.
Well, that's even better, actually, because, I mean, at the end of the day, I'm sure Morgan and Direct would probably back me up on this, maybe, that, I mean, you can be a really good remote viewer, but you could also not, because at the end of the day, even if you are, you're going to be submitting your data.
It's going to see if it lines up with everybody else as well.
And so it's really the aggregate information that is important.
So, I mean, as far as I'm concerned, it's better that you have a depth of knowledge that goes beyond that.
So I think what you were asking about non-human intelligence and the complication, like, one of the things that, one of the things that personally swayed me towards the concept that we're in a reality overlay, that we're in a form of simulation, is the level of complexity in the world.
Particularly around ideas, like, you were talking about factions, conspiracies, esoteric information.
And it's one of those features that they have in video games, and it's a technical term for it that I always forget.
But, you know, in a video game, you see limited information because at any given time, right, the rendering is the word.
Yeah, perfect.
So the video game renders, like, a small amount of the total potential environment in order to save power, basically.
And the further you go, the further you look, the more information you'll find, the more rooms in the game you'll find, the more worlds in the game you'll find, the more whatever it is type of game that you're playing.
And the same thing is true with, like, esoteric studies, like, there is no end to it, right?
So one of the things that some researchers have pointed out, and I agree with them, is that there's, you end up in this endless rabbit hole looking for the answers.
But the more answers you look for, the less likely you're ever to find the answer.
Because they keep, it's almost as if there's more data generated as you look.
And you can go back even years later and you find tons of stuff that you would, you'd never seen before.
And it always calls into question the other data.
I don't think it's possible to, just through research, find ultimate answers for that reason, which is why I think remote viewing data is important.
I think that that strongly supports the concept that we're in some sort of reality overlay or simulation that's designed to keep us from finding these ultimate answers.
When, what that means about non-human intelligence is, when we're looking at that, we have to divide it, we have to have, like, two lines, three lines.
We have three categories, right?
So the first category would be non-human intelligence within the simulation.
A second category would be non-human intelligence outside of the simulation that interacts with us within the simulation.
And the third category would be non-human intelligence outside the simulation that does not interact with us.
And that's information that we can perceive to some degree through remote viewing because it seems that remote viewing is a natural intuitive faculty of human beings prior to the simulation.
It seems that the whole purpose behind the simulation, the way that it happened because of how intuitive human beings are, that comes up directly in the data, that human beings were intuitive, but also tried to limit the effects of our actions on each other and the ramifications.
So we were put into this situation because of that intuitiveness, but we were changed to no longer limit the effects of our behaviors and our actions on others.
And that may have speculation.
I could speculate that may have freed up our intuition in some way for use by non-human intelligence.
If we are, in fact, in a simulation or reality overlay, just like we would use a simulation to come up with answers for the real world, those who put us here may be doing that as well.
Except that we wait a second, you're saying somewhere in a vat, we have these expanded psychic abilities and those are the ones being used so that they can do better remote viewing or so that they can come up with solutions for, I mean, where are these ideas coming from?
Right.
So, I mean, that gets into like a different topic for a different day, but, you know, you can argue that the way the mind works isn't like a filing cabinet.
And then, in fact, our mind is an organ of perception, our brain is an organ of perception, and that it's all remote viewing.
So, you can make that argument.
But, yes, it seems that our intuitive abilities are what make us prime for this experiment.
We can only speculate about how those intuitive abilities would be used, but it does seem that there's a relationship.
That was the purpose or a factor in this experiment.
Well, what it means about non-human intelligence is it's possible that we could remote view non-human intelligence that we don't interact with.
It seems that some of the data that Morgan has indicates there are three factions of not us involved.
We don't have any direct data of those, of two other factions, but we have knowledge of them because we're able to...
Okay, Alex, I got a message from you, but I can't look at it right now, but you're here, so I don't know if you really had to leave.
Maybe it's somebody else, and I'm just misreading it.
Yeah, so we know of their existence because of remote viewing, right?
So, we know they were interacted with the faction or not us that put us in this situation.
So, we're able to see that because we are able to use intuition and non-local perception at base level reality.
We know that we have experiences of non-human intelligence here.
Now, some of that could be real, right?
Like, just because we are us doesn't mean that we're not also them, right?
So, if we're in a reality overlay, then everything is us.
Everything is within our minds.
It doesn't mean that we're only here as human beings.
We've talked about, like, we might be here as animals as well on some level.
You know, and it's possible that there are, we could still be in a simulation.
We could still be in a reality overlay and have subterranean civilizations.
Oh, subterranean.
And just because I haven't heard it, JT, there's also the possibility that the simulation itself is what allows for remote viewing.
That remote viewing is a loophole enabled or is a byproduct of the simulation.
Okay, so that's a possibility, but that's not what the data shows.
The data shows the remote viewing.
Yeah, yeah, totally.
I'm with you there.
I'm just saying it is an option on the table.
Sure, it is.
It would make it, that would be, if you wanted to go down that path, then that would really sabotage our ability to see outside simulation and call that data into question.
I also, I have another perspective.
Yeah.
Because it seems to me that what we are comprised of is different bodies that relate to different, somebody calls it a reality stack or also dimensions.
And that you have an astral body for the astral, mental body for mental, pure spirit, soul, and probably something else I'll say.
Who knows?
But we do know about the astral body and a pretty good idea about the mind body.
I would say that what those were in those vats, I'd say it's really likely that, like, you know, your remote viewing data actually supports that we are multidimensional in that aspect as well.
Because there's spiritual evolution, like, these parts of us are not, are what's here, not just our physical body with neurons hooked together in the vats, right?
Like, we already, we have astral bodies, mental bodies there.
Those are projected down to here.
Okay, so that's interesting.
And so that's interesting, because there is an answer to that.
And the answer is, in a simulation scenario, the mental body, astral body that we experience now would be within the simulation, not without the simulation.
However, there is data from a remote viewer, not in Morgan's group, related to somebody attempting to leave their body outside of the simulation.
I don't, I'm not going to, like, go too far down that rabbit hole, but it does seem as if, it definitely does seem as if we are spiritual beings, and that's definitely part of Morgan's data.
We are spiritual beings outside of the simulation, however, like, what we'd experience as the astral body would be part of the, within the simulation, because the reincarnation process is entirely within the simulation that we experience right now.
So, the way that data talks about it, these are natural processes, and this is a mirror, like a, these have been, natural processes have been subverted and mirrored.
So, they would, they would exist outside, but right now, we're, we're trapped inside simulation.
As far as the non-human intelligence, is correct, or at least there's data that supports it being correct?
What, what, supports what being correct?
That we're, my assertion, that we have, so what I don't know is, I've never seen any data that suggests that there is a mental body, astral, etheric body, astral body, outside the simulation.
We can, we can, we can speculate there is, probably with good reason, because this is a mirror reality, right?
We know that there is a spiritual component to human beings that exists outside of the simulation, because that is why they, that is the other reason they targeted us.
That's being used as being, that's being used as some sort of battery, right?
So, like that, that spark, the mannequin spark of light, the, the divine spark, like that, that's definitely real, the, like the spirit or whatever is definitely real outside the simulation.
I just don't know about the various bodies outside, whether that is, is real in both senses.
Sorry about that.
I have a few points of data from people who do psychic projection, but they do it outside of the remote viewing sphere, sphere.
And so they kind of like do it off of intuition, but same thing, it's consciousness projection.
That's how I view remote viewing.
And so I have data that, of that person separately, somebody who's extraordinarily good at astral projecting and out of nowhere at like 38, she just did it and was super scientific and, you know, you know, scientific materials reductionist.
And, um, the consciousness projection person actually corroborated information with the other one.
And that is that this reality is a single point of consciousness of mind.
And then that mind is then mirrored and refracted out into a square and then into a cube.
And then in a tesseract kind of a matter, uh, manner, holographically, it is refracted and mirrored into this reality that we are in now.
And so you're like a concentrated version of yourself and everyone else's mind that's plugged into this place.
And that was corroborated by the astral projector.
Now she had a really interesting experience.
She started astral projecting out of nowhere at a later age and then, uh, went up.
And was like experiencing, you know, things like the shield around the earth.
There's some sort of a barrier that gets through that and goes even further astral projecting out and thinks she's coming towards a city.
Mind you, she's going up and she gets closer and closer and realizes it's not a city.
It's a gigantic circuit board.
And with like, you know, circuits as tall as towers.
And she touched it and instantly downloaded like a shit ton of information from the matrix.
And then, uh, absorbed it and then went back and did it again, got good at it.
And she found out a lot about this reality.
One was that, um, it's all of those refractions come out of the center of the earth.
And, you know, okay.
So she ended up projecting through the earth, just going center, center, center, center.
She just wants to get to the center, gets to it.
It's this giant glowing, you know, golden ball goes inside.
It wakes up in a body on a table and around her head is like a VR machine, but made of like really complicated crystals.
And she realized that's what she was in the matrix and she had plugged in it externally.
And then she described waving her hand, getting rid of it.
So mind you, just reality creation, pure reality creation, and then makes another one that is a pair of goggles instead.
Um, and then she put them back on and then boom, she's astral projecting in straight from the center of the earth and back to her body.
Um, I have another evidence, a guy on here called, uh, exit the matrix is his handle.
And he actually has a memory of phasing into this reality from like lying on a bench kind of thing.
And both of them described being in that state.
And basically Jordan actually explains it better, more, more complicated matter says in that reality, at least they were, um, all those aspects of us, all those bodies, except completely together, like as one thing, like you would never astral project in that body.
Because it's completely one thing, not these separated, extra astral, extra this, extra that, and she just, and he describes it as like all of those together.
And that's our natural state.
And so, um, I don't know, that's like two minor doubts.
No, no, no, that's great.
So how about this?
How about, um, cause there are a couple of things that, uh, you brought up.
I want to touch base on, right.
And then we'll save the rest of that for your, uh, your space.
Um, if that's all right with you.
And then we can, we can talk about the, the crystals and Jordan further if we don't answer it all here.
Um, so, okay.
So this, this touches on the, I was trying to bring up the third category, right?
And I know we had to, we had to clarify some other points, but I, I need to circle back.
There is a possibility that we're in a simulation and we're, um, interacting with beings outside the simulation.
The same way you would put on a virtual headset, virtual reality headset and go into a simulation.
Now, our data is a lot darker than the data that you're, you're talking about.
Um, however, the basic concept is, is, is there.
Is the same.
And we look at it from a perspective of like, potentially some of the more negative behavior that happens here.
Um, and I have, you know, pointed out like how people interest when they're in like Grand Theft Auto or Red Dead, Dead Resemption.
I know I'm not, I'm just picking names.
I'm not a video gamer, but you know, you get a lot of griefing, right?
And griefing is when you go into these online games and, and commit every violation you can possibly commit within the,
frame of the game.
And so if we are interacting with non-human intelligence outside the simulation, they may be here as a form of recreation.
And they may be here grief.
They definitely may be a reason why they're so manipulative and deceptive, but it also may be a reason why there are so many like unreasonable sort of evil things that happen in the world.
Particularly when we're looking at like the allegations against like our, you know, our ruling class and allegations of things that they've supposedly done.
Um, and just random events.
When you have people who experience like a demonic possession scenario, uh, that it is.
And I think the data definitely shows that Morgan's data shows that both the kind of immaterial beings from outside of the simulation and also the comment, the concept of an avatar, uh, which is beings from outside the simulation, forming avatars, ships, and bodies here in the simulation in order to interact with us.
So what, the reason that's relevant to what you said was if we talk about like, could there be other civilizations in the moon, on Mars, on Saturn, uh, underground, at the bottom of the ocean?
Yes.
However, they could be three things.
They could be us.
Um, they could be generated, auto-generated as part of the, part of this dream that we're in and, and not really be conscious sentient beings, but just be artifacts of the dream that we're in.
Um, or they could be avatars from, um, beings outside the game who are here for recreational purposes or research purposes or some purpose that we can't quite understand.
Um, when it gets into that other information, um, Jordan and exit the matrix, um, I think they're very nice people.
Uh, there are, that exit the matrix specifically, there are a lot of holes in his story and I, I, I don't, I'm not here to troll people.
Um, so I, I, I didn't stick around and fight with him, but I, I did point out to him that, you know, he was saying some things that, that don't logically add up.
Um, and his perception of himself as an avatar or being that's here to save people doesn't match up with his, his life.
All right.
Um, you know, avatars are part of a community.
It's a two part deal if you believe in them, right?
If you believe that avatars come and they, um, they're here to help and change humanity, the way they do that is by building a community around them.
They don't do it themselves.
Uh, so if you have somebody who obviously has issues, um, with that aspect of their life, like you say, well, okay, if you're an avatar, where's your community, right?
In real life, where's your community?
Um, when you go to his, his page, he gets a lot of comments from LARPers.
I guess a lot of comments from people who are playing alternative reality games, which is something that happens a lot on X right now.
It's, it's what Reddit was designed for testing.
And then X has become the, the mode for, um, the mode for the nexus for running the alternative reality games.
And it's something we're going to do a space on in the future.
Um, but a lot of this, a lot of these communities are at, at, at their heart being run as a, as a game and it's a new and more efficient way of, we believe new and more efficient way of, um, organizing society, um, that you're familiar with from Reddit and also from Q phenomenon, right?
Uh, when I, when I, when I have interacted with X of the matrix, I've seen that he, he tends to interact with.
People who are obviously involved in alternative reality games, probably a lot of bots.
Um, but definitely a lot of people who are, who are LARPing.
Um, I, I think he's probably a decent person, but I wonder if he deceives himself.
And that's what I brought up to him because his, his just, his whole story doesn't really add up, right?
Like you say he was sitting on a park bench and then he came here.
Well, you know, if he was sitting on a park bench and then he came where we are, he would be in a basement, um, under a facility in a base reality based on our data.
Um, instead you're saying he was sitting in a park bench and then he was in our collective dream, which is what this is.
Um, so if he's sitting in a park bench someplace dreaming and he was somehow able to travel into our collective dream, I mean, I guess that's possible, right?
Um, but it would definitely call into question the rest of his story about what he's here for and having been here for four reincarnations, which is, which is what he says.
Uh, because reincarnations in the context of our experience are, are a part of this reality overlay.
Um, if he was having foreign reincarnations without physically being where we are physically, um, then he would probably be having them like out in the universe and not here.
And it's just, there are just the problems and I'd have to go back and review my notes, meaning the post that I sent to him, uh, for what problems I saw.
But I, I don't, um, I don't believe.
Yeah.
Jordan's got a lot of problems.
So let me, no, let me address that.
Right.
So Jordan is Jordan's brother.
Is that, is that what you're talking about?
Jordan?
Uh, no, I was talking about, uh, exit matrix.
Oh, his name is Jordan.
Is.
Oh, okay.
His name is Jordan.
I don't know his last name.
I thought it was two people.
Yeah, no, there are just some, some problems.
I think he may be engaged in some, some self-deception.
And, um, I, I wanted to prompt him into that the same way he's trying to tell everyone else because he would be in the same, like he would be in the same way.
Same situation, right.
Of being somebody who would be in trouble if they didn't wake up to that fact.
Um, as far as like the astral travel is concerned, the problem that I have, and I'm not, I'm not a remote viewer and I don't know what Morgan would say about this.
Right.
But, um, like it's a, it's a, it's a, it seems to be a real phenomenon.
There are other ways to have these experiences.
Um, remote viewing is non-local perception, but it's not necessarily a projecting of consciousness.
Uh, maybe it is, and I'm not telling you you're wrong.
I'm just saying it isn't necessarily that.
Um, however, the difference between a remote viewer and someone who does like, um, uh, astral projection, um, would be the remote viewing is designed to weed out analytical overlay.
Whereas astral projection is designed to almost create, um, analytical overlay, um, to create metaphorical and allegorical interactions with, um, reality on a certain level.
Um, there's definitely nothing that I'm aware of in astral body projection where people are trained to omit or to, um, I don't know who requested, whoever requests can come up.
Um, oh, I thought Will had already, I thought Will was already up here.
Uh, right, right.
Like that's what, um, yeah.
So that's, that's the thing, right?
Like it's not, astral body projection is real.
It's interesting, but it's generally not used as a, as a method of obtaining data, reliable data, because it is, it's very metaphorical.
And it's, there's a lot of, quote, what we'd say reality overlay and visual, um, represent, and that's not even getting to the deception around human entities.
If they're interacting with non-human entities, I don't know if he's in a crystal, if he was in a crystal.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Like you could, uh, you could have multiple people astral projecting to the same place at the same time.
Sure.
But let me tell you another thing, another thing that you got to think about, right?
Um, uh, remote viewers who look into this subject are deeply traumatized by it.
I have, uh, uh, uniformly have traumatic, post-traumatic stress reactions to looking into the details of how the, um, reality overlay works and whether this is a simulation or not.
They're very traumatic and people who have, uh, traumatic, um, they're trained, right?
As I pointed out, they're trained to bring back the information as accurately as possible.
However, other people who are not trained, who have access to deeply traumatic information have, um, you know, pretty, um, predictable psychological reactions.
And some of those psychological reactions involve disassociation from reality, right?
And, and, and creating, uh, fantasies as, as, as a means of not facing the reality.
So the fact that remote viewers who look into this subject are traumatized and see horrible things, but astral body people who astral body project, see like crystal tables and beautiful cities.
Like to me, the first thing that suggests is that, um, that what the astral body people who are astral body projecting is seeing as a trauma reaction.
Right.
That's what it seems to me.
That's what, that's what I would say.
Like without further study, I couldn't say either way, but I would be very suspicious of anything that someone said, the fact that astral body people who practice astral body projecting, see something entirely different than what remote viewers report.
And they see something that seems to be consistent with an escapist fantasy, in my opinion.
Uh, well, what do you got?
Um, I was going to say, I'm an out of body remote viewer.
I initiate an out of body, go to the target in an envelope, completely blind to myself and know a monitor.
And I can go hit that target, come back, draw it out, describe it or whatever, go back, come back, do it again, go do it over and over and over.
How would you compare that to astral body travel?
Do you believe that that's the same thing?
The silver cord, astral body travel, different realms, Monroe gateway, do you, do you see that as the same thing as what you're doing?
Or do you see you yourself as a remote viewer who has the perception of being there physically or out of body?
Well, I can follow the remote view, uh, remote viewing protocols for, um, this, uh, for CRV, combine that with, uh, Monroe Institute, um, out of body remote view, you know, going out of body.
Okay.
What I'm saying though, is that the Monroe Institute material involved a lot of very elaborate visualization.
Are you in that same, are you having that same experience?
Oh yeah, I can do the, uh, I sense everything, go to the target.
I'll actually see it, but I'll also see the framework.
And when I'm doing the initial sketches, I'm, uh, doing the primary, um, primary gestalt, uh, the sensation of the site, uh, squiggles on the lines, broken lines, whatever, stuff like that.
So, okay.
Follow that all the way to step by step.
Oh, no, that's good.
What I'm saying specifically is Robert Monroe went to the astral realm, went to various planes in the astral realm, went to planes where there were millions of people standing around and then a God would come by on a road and everyone would have to bow and put their face to the ground because they would be destroyed if they saw the God coming by in the, in the parade.
And then he would go to places where they had giant highways going through space.
And those highways would be filled with, with beings going to, to certain places.
Um, you know, so there was a lot of like very metaphorical visual data involved in, in Robert Monroe.
And so when you think of astral body traveling, you really think of people going to the etheric plane, the astral plane, you think of people going to hell planes, you think of people going to heaven planes, you think of people seeing angels and demons and monsters.
Um, like that's the gateway experience.
It sounds to me like.
For me, it's planets and straight up other galaxies.
Oh, so you do go to places like that.
Okay.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Deramina, Arturia, that stuff.
Well, that's cool.
That's great.
Have you ever looked into, uh, the simulation theory?
Uh, that, what, this is a matrix and it's all just a computer simulation.
No, I, I never, I never looked into any of that kind of stuff.
I avoided the subject cause I never, I never had to go looking for it.
It found me and it's been part of my life since I was four and a half.
Um, Hal put off and Russell Targ, uh, tested to me on a remote viewing target.
And then we went to the target and they were like, is this what you saw?
And I immediately went, yes, this is a pile of crystals was salt.
And I described it as diamonds and diamonds before they're cut and polished look like rock salt up close.
And there were other things about the building itself.
It was a large white building, thick red line along the wall and along the edge.
The salt had, uh, taken on some of the color from the red and it was bleeding into the salt and it was making it gratings of pink.
But that's, that sounds really amazing.
That's an amazing life experience to have.
I was only asking specific to, um, and no, we, we don't, when we look at simulation, we don't think it's, we're inside a computer.
We think that we're, um, we're in sort of a collective dream, but that haven't been said.
Um, we're contrasting comparing the data that people gain from remote viewing, the nature of the reality overlay versus, um, astral body traveling and what they see then and there.
So it seems to me like that you haven't astral body traveled or remote viewed that specific data that you're aware of.
No, um, never seen any crowds like that, but I have seen some wild stuff, um, uh, crystal city, uh, kind of flying down the street, meeting up with a woman and a little girl watching a dual sunset and a purple night sky lit up with stars.
Um, completely, completely, completely alien visuals to earth, nothing even remotely close to seeing what we see here.
So much more impressive, uh, another spot was, uh, along the coastline with a jungle, large, uh, towers with gigantic discs and, uh, one side, uh, kind of holding on to the large tower and sticking over.
And there were five or six, five or six of these almost cloud city looking things, just not centered on the middle, but kind of off on the edge and kind of sticking straight out.
And the tops of these things, these big round discs all look like UFOs, basically that, you know, the typical big disc UFOs.
And these things were huge, like two, 300 feet long and three or four stories tall.
That's amazing.
I'd see that's the type of stuff.
Like if I were to choose, if I had one ability or the other, I personally, um, maybe I'm a little escapist, but I would like to be able to astral body travel and see things like that and hope that those were type of worlds that I could end up in someday.
And maybe, you know, maybe leave this one behind.
That's my personal escapist bent, but that would be what I would be interested in.
Um, Joseph was going to run a space and I was hoping that we would have the link up in the nest, but the link is not up in the nest yet.
Um, but our goal was to kind of bounce out of here at seven and go to Joseph's space, um, and talk more about, because I think that Morgan specifically has information like Morgan has information about the origin of the universe, but also the source of the universe.
And one of them is information that would relate to the reality overlay, which we might disagree on.
But the other information is about how the universe outside the reality overlay works.
And that sounded very similar to my ears to what Joseph was talking about with the point of consciousness and the geometric shapes and whatever that seemed, I don't know, maybe I'm confabulating, but that seemed like,
there could be a relationship.
So I think that Morgan could talk about that a little bit.
And he does have a, you may not have it right now, but Morgan, you have a couple of drawings too.
You might want to bring to Joseph's space and throw up in the nest there.
Um, but since it is seven o'clock, can we get a link to your space, Joseph, so we can start the transition maybe?
Uh, yeah, I was just going to mention, so there was, there was a little misunderstanding, uh, I guess Joseph didn't realize, uh, we're on, uh, Eastern time.
So it is in fact seven for us right now, but, uh, it looks like Joseph is on Pacific time.
Oh, you're kidding.
Yeah.
So, no, it was just a misunderstanding.
No, that's cool.
It's, uh, I, I changed the time for right now.
I put, uh, the space in your, um, inboxes, but I can't send it to me, but I don't know how to put it in the nest.
Uh, so I got to try to put Morgan and Morgan can nest it or whatever that is.
Oh, okay.
I see.
Yep.
I got, I got it.
Um, you, oh, I didn't notice you changed the time.
Okay.
So we are doing that right now then.
Yeah.
Yeah, that sounds good.
Okay.
Right on.
I will give me two seconds and I will, um, uh, I'm going to do this.
Just copy that.
All right.
I'll, I'll go.
Beauty, man.
We'll see you there shortly.
Okay.
Cool.
We're going to be right there.
I'm going to get a sandwich, but I'll be there.
Uh, uh, Morgan, um, while you're putting that in the nest, I'm going to do the wrap up,
but thank you all for coming.
Will, uh, Joseph, Doomer, uh, direct, Aaron, miss, uh, thank.
I'm sure there's more to it, but I, Diogenes, blue, bark, bark, like something, Dr. Policy.
Thank you all for joining us.
I hope you'll join Joseph.
He's going to talk more about the reality overlay and different opinions about the simulation.
It seems like you might have a, a different opinion on ours, but it's always good to hear
people's opinions.
And honestly, um, when people have sort of a love and light opinion, um, it's, I hope it's
true.
I would much rather wake up in a crystal bed and, you know, in a crystal city and shit and
have like all this amazing stuff happen than, than to wake up and sort of a harsh, really
sort of nightmarish, hella situation.
So hopefully Morgan can get that up in the nest.
I still don't see it, but, um, it should be listed under spaces.
If you guys look for your own spaces and that's Morgan Farrell, paramount grandmaster remote
viewer, in my opinion.
Um, his, uh, his website is intuitive underground.com.
Um, his, um, I think the other one is learn remote viewing.
I always screw it up, but, uh, .com.
I do not have a website.
I'm available through, uh, direct messaging.
I'm available for consultations if anyone has an interest, but I'm not here for that.
Like I'm not trying to drum up business.
Um, I should probably get a website and, uh, we do have a discord server.
Um, I will post the discord server link again.
They do expire fairly regularly.
So I'll have to put another one up, but if you follow me, um, you'll see the link to the
discord server.
If you want to join, I would follow Morgan as well.
Um, I would follow him before I'd follow me and, um, yeah, so we're going to, uh, do that
transition and, um, and go, Oh, I guess it is in the nest.
I just can't see it.
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
I'm going to, uh, I'm going to make just a regular post about it as well.
Um, okay.
Yeah, I was, I was thinking that there's a link to the space, but it's, it's something
about that woman.
Um, someone apparently wanted to stop by.
They didn't want to talk.
They just wanted to post a video by, um, a woman who credits herself with being the best
Vedic astrologer in the world.
Uh, she is of course a Texan and, um, I'll just leave it at that.
Uh, from what I understand, she's not horrible.
Um, but she's not the best Vedic astrologer.
So everyone, um, Monday, uh, six o'clock PM Eastern standard time, uh, we're going to,
um, read a letter post written, uh, about us on Reddit.
We're going to add some commentary about it because the, um, attempted bullying, mobbing,
canceling, um, that happens in some of these communities has kept a lot of this information
away from public, uh, the public awareness because people in the rope viewing community
don't want to go through it.
Um, that's what this dude is trying to do to us.
And I don't really care.
I'm in the removing community, so I don't, they can't do a goddamn thing to me.
Um, I don't need to worry about what, you know, Daz thinks of me or whoever, anyone else, right?
Um, however, it's, it's just something we have to sort of discuss.
And then on, uh, Thursday, um, thinking about the end of the world and that will be posted,
uh, tonight.
Thank you for coming.
There's going to be like a 15 second space before we drop.
I'll be over there with, uh, Joseph.
I am going to get a sandwich first, so it might be a minute.
And, uh, we appreciate you all.
Um, yeah, thanks everybody.
And, uh, I'm friendly with Daz for the record.
Oh, yes.
I don't have to worry about Daz.
I didn't know.
Did I criticize Daz?
No.
Is that coming?
It's probably going to come at some point, but I, I, we've talked to you about that and
I gave you the opportunity to, um, right to, uh, I gave you a veto and we talked about
that the, uh, the other night.
So, but I have, uh, I have, uh, uh, I don't know.
Posted the updated link in the nest.
Awesome.
Um, we post it, uh, just on timeline as well.
So hope to see you guys over there shortly.
All right.
I'm going back to the 15 seconds before we drop it.
So that's why I do.
Okay.